Hello
Da bin ich ja ich war auf dem Klo
Leute ich merke ganz schön meine Oberschenkel ich bin vorher schon wieder meine Runde gefahren
Hat er gesagt ich dachte das ist so ein ultra krasser Rust Fan das glaube ich nicht
Windows, oh ne please, kein Windows Update ich musste ein Windows Update auf der Arbeit machen zwei Stunden konnte ich mein Notebook nicht verwenden
Aber Go ist nicht blazingly fast was ist denn Go?
Zwei Stunden ja zwei Stunden Notebook Wartung musste gefühlt 50 Mal Rebooten bis es dann funktioniert hat
Ne ne ne, Go ist nicht insanely fast wenn Rust blazingly fast ist so geht das ja nicht
Ich starte mal meine VM und mach mal Updates
Ich kann euch an der Stelle mal erzählen ich habe mein Fahrrad kaputt gemacht mein neues
Aber aber nicht aber nicht so kaputt wie das letzte Mal
Das letzte mal hat mich eine mit dem Auto um gefahren totalschaden
Nein wirklich wirklich und zwar am Wochenende, ja Wochenende war es, am Wochenende
Habe ich gedacht
Hab ich gedacht
Ich schraub mal selbst ein bisschen. Nein nein nein, nein der Rahmen ist nicht kaputt
Aber ich konnte jetzt ein paar Tage nicht fahren weil ich es kaputt gemacht habe
Und zwar ich dachte mir so am Wochenende weiß was
Du schraubst mal selbst was...
mal selbst ein bisschen was dran rum.
Nein, 14 Tage. Doch, 14 Tage
sind schon vorbei. Aber ich will es auch nicht zurückgeben.
Also, und zwar, ich dachte mir, ich schraube ein bisschen
selbst dran rum. Ich mache mal hier Package-Updates
inzwischen Zeit. Und zwar, was ich vorhatte, ist folgendes.
Richtig.
Das erste,
was ich machen wollte, ist die Kassette austauschen.
Standardmäßig ist eine
11 bis 34 Kassette drin.
Und ich wollte eine
11 bis 40 Kassette
drauf machen, dass ich ein bisschen mehr
Oma-Gang habe, wenn es den Berg hoch geht.
Und das ist zwar leicht
außerhalb der Spezifikation
für meine Schaltung,
aber kein Problem. Das habe ich auch
zig YouTube-Videos gesehen. Das frisst das Ding und es
funktioniert. So.
Fahrradschrauberkurs. Ja, es wäre vielleicht
nicht verkehrt, wenn ich den auch gemacht hätte.
Zumindest habe ich mir bei der Gelegenheit
gedacht, wenn ich schon die
Kassette tausche
von meinem Fahrrad,
dann bedeutet das ja, die neue
Kassette, also Kassette ist das Ding hinten.
Das, was die
die Zahnräder, die man hinten hat
an einem Fahrrad, ja.
Wer da mit den Fachbegriffen nicht so
vertraut ist, das ist eine Kassette.
Ja, so ein Ding habe ich auch
hier, sowas zum Abmachen.
Und da dachte ich mir so, ja,
wenn du jetzt die neue Kassette drauf machst,
dann ist die ja
ölfrei.
Doch
eine Kassette setzt sich aus Ritzel
zusammen. Ritzel sind die
einzelnen Zahnräder auf so einer Kassette.
Und Ritzel,
Ritzel werden angegeben mit der Anzahl der Zähne.
Was, mittlerweile streamt man Musik?
Macht man das?
Wolltest du dein Fahrrad flashen?
Ich hab mein Fahrrad geflasht!
Ich hab mein Fahrrad geflasht.
Ich hab ja eine elektronische Schaltung.
Ich hab Firmware-Update gemacht, letztens.
Ich hab mein, ich hab,
seriously, ich hab mein Fahrrad geflasht, kein Witz.
Aber mit der offiziellen,
mit der offiziellen Firmware und der offiziellen
App. Die App ist übrigens
richtig scheiße.
Anders kann ich's nicht sagen, ey.
Keine Ahnung, was sich die Highly Paid Professionals
von Shimano dabei gedacht haben,
aber die App ist richtig
kacke. Wenn du, passt mal auf,
nur um euch mal zu erläutern,
wie scheiße die App ist.
Du machst die App auf,
connectest deine
Schaltung,
dann schließt du
die App oder
sperrst dein Telefon und lässt die
zu lange inaktiv,
dann geht deine Schaltung nicht mehr,
weil du die Schaltung nicht ordnungsgemäß
disconnected hast.
Das Ding resettet sich nicht von allein.
Und die App hat dann aber
vergessen, dass sie connected ist.
Dann musst du erstmal deine Schaltung
wieder neu pären und rebooten,
quasi, dass es funktioniert. Das ist
richtig scheiße gemacht, ja. Richtig
scheiße.
So, aber, während wir Updates machen.
Genau, also, was ich euch eigentlich erzählen
wollte, ich wollte die Kassette tauschen,
ja. Also, hier
hinten, das dran. Hab ich gemacht
und so eine neue Kassette,
kommt komplett ohne Öl
und ohne Fett drauf.
Weil man ölt und fettet seine
Fetten, Entschuldigung, man ölt seine, oder, oder, ja.
Ähm,
seine Kassette eh nicht, sondern nur
die Kette.
Bei der Gelegenheit hab ich mir auch noch eine neue
Kette gekauft und hab mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Ich wachs jetzt mal meine Kette.
Also nicht hier irgendwie, sondern
richtig wortwörtlich genommen.
Und dann hab ich meine neue
Kette entfettet
und gewachst.
Eingefädelt.
Hat auch wunderbar
funktioniert. Hoch und runter
geschaltet, hat sich gut angehört, war ein bisschen
viel Wachs dran und so, eigentlich alles gut.
Und dann hab ich festgestellt,
Mist.
Also, ich musste auch die Schaltung ein bisschen
weiter runterdrehen, damit
die 40er Kassette draufpasst.
So, alles gut, funktioniert wunderbar.
Und dann guck ich auf
die Kette
und stell fest, Mist,
ich hab sie falschrum eingebaut.
Das Video kenn ich,
das ist nice, das hab ich schon geguckt.
Ich hab die Kette falschrum eingebaut.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Also, Kettenschloss wieder aufgemacht,
Kette rumgedreht,
wieder eingefädelt
und dann
ist mir aufgefallen, Mist,
die krieg ich ja
gar nicht mehr zu, weil
dann müsste ich erst
runterschalten auf den kleinsten Gang, kein Problem.
Und ich müsste das
die Schaltung wieder ein bisschen
rausdrehen, dass halt die Kette
genug Spielraum hat, dass ich sie zusammenkriege.
Also, was hab ich gemacht?
Faul wie ich war,
ich hab einfach unten diesen Käfig vom Schaltwerk
von Hand nach vorne gedrückt,
sodass die Kette wieder genug Spielraum hat,
um es zusammenzuklemmen.
Nachdem ich allerdings
beide Hände brauche,
um das Kettenschloss
an der Kette, das sieht dann so aus,
ich zeig euch da mal ein Bild zu,
so sieht so ein Kettenschloss aus
für die Kette.
Nachdem ich beide Hände gebraucht hab,
um die Kette zuzumachen,
hab ich einfach mein Knie
hinter den Käfig
von der Schaltung geklemmt,
sodass dies vorne bleibt.
Da ist schon einiges an Spannung drauf.
Ja, und irgendwie
hatte ich da mein Knie
zu fest und zu schräg dran.
Danach war der Käfig verbogen
von meiner Schaltung.
Und ich hab mich erst
gewundert, das war auch sehr akrobatisch,
und ich hab mich erst gewundert,
warum die auf einmal
nicht mehr ordentlich schaltet danach.
Ich hab alles ausprobiert,
adjusted,
und sonst wieder gesagt,
was ist das für ne Scheiße, Mann,
warum geht das nicht?
Ich hab einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch gehabt,
was ist das für ne Scheiße, eben ging's doch noch,
und was soll der Kack?
So, und
naja, was hab ich
gemacht? Ich hab halt
gleich mal
prophylaktisch eine neue Schaltung bestellt.
Ich hätte auch einfach nur ein Käfig bestellen können,
aber ich hab
praktisch, weil ich brauch bestimmt eh noch mal eine,
weil irgendwann mal was kaputt geht,
eine neue Schaltung bestellt.
Das ist eine elektronische Schaltung, die kostet halt einfach gleich mal 270 Euro.
Aber man gönnt sich ja sonst nix.
Die hab ich gestern dran geschraubt,
und danach hat wieder alles perfekt geschaltet.
Und heute bin ich ne runde Probe
gefahren, und ich sag euch, ey,
ich hatte ein bisschen Schiss,
weil ich vergessen hab, das Kettenschloss
zu wechseln. Ich hatte das Kettenschloss
dran, was ich schon irgendwie 7-8 Mal gewechselt habe.
Und der Hersteller sagt, man darf es
nur einmal verwenden, aber drauf geschissen.
Ich hab immer quasi heute beim Fahren drauf
gewartet, dass die Kette auseinanderfällt, aber ist nix
passiert.
Zumindest, ich hab so ein wieder verstellbares Kettenschloss mir
jetzt gekauft, ist kein Problem. Zumindest
heute bin ich ne Runde gefahren mit
frisch gewachster
Kette,
und ein bisschen größerer Übersetzung, also
einfacheren Gängen für berghoch.
Und ich bin die gleiche Strecke gefahren
wie das letzte Mal, und heute hat
ich leider meine Wattmessungspedale
noch nicht dran.
Ich bin die gleiche
Strecke gefahren wie das letzte Mal,
zum Testen. Heute war ich
1 kmh schneller als das letzte Mal,
und hatte 6,
ja knapp 6
Herzschläge, Puls weniger,
als das letzte Mal. Also,
scheint zu flutschen, ja.
Oder ich hatte weniger nervige Gassigänger
und Rentner auf der Straße, das kann auch
sein. Man weiß
es nicht.
Sadge, was ist hier eigentlich los?
Ich sehe das,
ich sehe das gerade. Zu viel
Fahrradtalk anscheinend, oder Twitch hat es noch nicht
gecheckt, oder ist gerade irgendwas?
Ist gerade irgendwas? Weil normalerweise
dauert es keine 2 Minuten, dann
sind es so 130, 140 Leute,
und nicht nach einer Viertelstunde 85.
Wahrscheinlich interessiert
alle keinen Go, Sadge.
Aber, kann man nichts machen.
Heute wird Go
gestelzt.
Also, offiziell sagt der Hersteller,
das Kettenschloss ist, man darf es genau
einmal verwenden.
Aber die sagen wahrscheinlich viel, wenn der Tag lang ist,
einfach um mehr zu verkaufen, ja.
Ich mache doch immer Side-Tracking.
Die erste Viertelstunde.
Lerne C an der
TH und weiß schon alles.
Denkst du?
Oder weißt du? Also, denkst du, du weißt
schon alles, oder bist du dir sicher?
Ja, denke ich auch.
Aber ich merke es echt im Bein.
Wir müssen gerade nochmal die IDS updaten.
Gucken, ob wir
die letzte Version
Go Land haben. Und da erzähle ich euch auch,
was wir in Go basteln.
Leute, ich habe ja letztens während
des hier... Oh nein! Nein!
Nicht wieder der Kack-Bug!
Was ist das denn, Mann?
Die letzten Male ging es doch alles wunderbar.
Nicht wieder
dieser Bug!
Jetzt crasht es wieder, wenn ich Jetbrains,
die Jetbrains Toolbox aufmache.
Fucking Shit, Mann!
Das ist irgendein VMware-Windows-Bug!
Irgendein
dummer VMware-Windows-Bug!
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für ein Schrott
ist, Mann!
Das ist so... Alter!
Was ist das denn?
Ich meine, ich weiß,
ich weiß, wie man das fixt.
Man muss VMware abschießen.
Wo ist es denn überhaupt?
Sieht es jemand? Wo ist VMware?
Ja, VMware Workstation.
Bam!
Oh, VMware muss man abschießen.
Da muss man VMware neu aufmachen und dann
irgendwann geht es.
Wohl auch nicht.
Doch, jetzt geht es.
Was ein Schrott, Alter!
Äh,
jetzt hängt es wieder?
Oh, nein!
Oh, Crashke!
VMware will nicht, dass du das
in der VMware...
PostChamp?
Alter, was ist denn jetzt,
Mann!
Nice!
Okay.
Prozessexplorer öffnen.
Nach CPU sortieren.
VMware, hier.
VMware muss weg.
Okay, ich glaube jetzt, ich glaube jetzt,
ich glaube jetzt geht es wieder.
Brake. Brake.
Okay. Brake.
Ah, okay.
Mann, ey!
Hier sind die Gefahren von C++
für Minderjährige.
Ja, also
man sollte auch, man sollte auch
mindestens 21 sein, um
C++ ertragen zu können.
Also, ich verstehe das schon.
Du musst die Leute vor sich selbst schützen.
Ne, Link ist nicht
gefährlich. Das ist
Hacker News.
ChatGPT gibt ihm keine Antwort
auf C++-Fragen, weil er nicht 18 ist.
Verständlich.
Leute, ich habe es heute auf Twitter geschrieben.
Sorry, auf X.
Auf X habe ich es geschrieben.
Auf X.
Oder wie auch immer man das richtig ausspricht.
Ich habe heute jemand vor mir gehabt, der hatte Schuhe an
mit goldenen Vorhängeschlössern dran.
Kein Witz.
Und ich dachte mir, das ist irgendein Jugendtrend.
Aber anscheinend
ist es das nicht.
Ich dachte, das ist vielleicht irgendein Jugendtrend, den ich als Boomer wieder nicht checke.
Hätte ja sein können.
Aber
das ist es nicht.
Leute, die Toolbox ist im Arsch.
Ich mache nichts.
Ich bewege die Maus nicht.
Ich warte, bis es gestartet ist.
Okay?
Jetzt gehe ich hier hin, check update
und gucke, ob GoLand gestartet ist.
Alles klar. Und jetzt mache ich ganz schnell wieder zu, nicht, dass es gleich wieder crasht.
Okay.
Wunderbar.
Es war kein...
Es war...
Twitter ist auch schlau.
Jeder hat mir gesagt, das ist eine Schuhmarke,
die sich Bus
Chemischuhe oder so nennt.
Und guckt,
die gibt es mit, sowas war das in der Richtung.
Das waren Schuhe
mit Schlössern, mit goldenen Schlössern hintendran.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe,
what the fuck.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Was das sein soll.
Das sind Schuhe mit goldenen Vorhängeschlössern dran.
Ich weiß, ich weiß doch auch nicht,
warum.
Aber es sind Schuhe mit goldenen Vorhängeschlössern dran.
Guck, sowas in der Richtung hatte der an.
Wobei es mehr Turnschuh-mäßig aussah, was der anhatte.
Sieht arschteuer aus, naja.
Kosten 670
Pfund, hier 740 Euro.
Ja, wer goldene Vorhängeschlösser will,
die 2,50 Euro bei den China-Chinesen kosten,
der muss schon mal 600, 700 Euro
latzen. Dafür kriege ich
drei extraweit...
Ich brauche ja extraweit Schuhe,
habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt, weil ich so fette...
Fett sind die gar nicht mal.
Breit sind die halt, Füße hab.
Ich brauche extra, extra breite
Schuhe. Und die sind auch teuer
as fuck. Aber davon kriege ich,
davon kriege ich, drei reichen,
für den Preis von denen kriege ich
eigentlich fast schon vier.
Naja, also, ich erzähle euch
mal, ich erzähle euch mal, was wir in Go machen.
Wir müssen heute mal ein bisschen was
ausprobieren.
Und zwar, also,
auf der Arbeit,
ich habe euch schon ein paar mal erzählt,
ich bin dort, unter anderem
in einem Projekt, wo es
um Blockchain-Technologie
geht.
Eigentlich ist das schon wieder outdated, overrated,
jebaited, aber ihr könnt euch überlegen, wenn
jetzt gerade Versicherungen und
Banken und die Finanzbranche, so die
richtigen, richtigen oldschool
Finanzunternehmen damit anfangen,
die fangen immer erst mit sowas an,
wenn der Hype eigentlich schon vorbei ist.
Doomsweb, danke schön für den Sub.
Heißt im Endeffekt, diese
sind da immer ein bisschen hinten dran.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt auch
Cagbusiness-Blockchain.
So, wir betreiben einige
Blockchain-Nodes,
nennt sich das,
selber. Unter anderem
betreiben wir
Polygon-Blockchain-Nodes.
Das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel, wir haben noch mehr,
aber Polygon ist,
glaube ich, mit das bekannteste
von dem, was wir betreiben.
Und
das Ding ist,
dass
das Monitoring oder die Überwachung
von diesen Polygon-
Containern
ziemlich
suboptimal ist.
Also die hängen öfters mal,
wegen irgendwelchen Sachen,
das sind wir nicht die einzigen, die Probleme haben,
und man bekommt es nicht richtig mit.
Aber
man kann die über eine API abfragen,
was ist denn dein letzter
Block, den du gesehen hast?
Und dann kann man noch eine zweite Abfrage machen,
sag mir mal den Timestamp
vom aktuellen Block.
Und dann kannst du den aktuellen
Timestamp nehmen,
minus aktuelle Uhrzeit, und dann weißt du,
wie alt dein Block ist.
Das dumme ist nur, dass
diese Metriken, oder diese
Infos, die musst du dir selbst
zusammenbauen.
Das bietet die Software, die wir verwenden,
dafür nicht an. Unsere Software
bietet nur die Info an,
was letzter Block.
Deswegen
habe ich vorgeschlagen,
wisst ihr was, wir bauen
einfach, wir betreiben das ganze im Kubernetes-Cluster,
wir machen heute nix mit Kubernetes, wir machen
wirklich ein bisschen Go gebastelt.
Deswegen habe ich gesagt, wisst ihr was,
was haltet ihr denn davon,
wenn wir
neben den ganzen Blockchain-Sachen
noch einen eigenen
Pod bauen, also einen eigenen
Container bauen, und den mitdeployen
ins Kubernetes,
der diese Metriken bereitstellt.
In Kubernetes
Fachkreis nennt man sowas
Sidecar-Container,
also man packt quasi noch
einen weiteren Container
in das Deployment dabei,
der dann nur Metriken bereitstellt.
Und wie stellt man am besten
Metriken bereit, Chat?
Cloud Native, Hyper Agile,
mit was macht man das?
Was ist da angesagt?
Wer weiß es?
Vor allem, wo hat Google eine gute Unterstützung
dafür?
Ich pause-champ jetzt so lange, bis irgendeiner
irgendwas sagt, auch wenn es falsch ist.
Prometheus, richtig!
Ja, Gott sei Dank, ey, ich hätte schon gern was.
Ich habe gerade echt überlegt, was mache ich denn?
Was mache ich denn, wenn jetzt keiner was sagt?
Prometheus,
korrekt.
Zumal Google auch schon Managed Prometheus
anbietet, und das haben wir
testweise in Benutzung. Deswegen
möchte ich in Go
einen Prometheus-Exporter bauen,
der die API abfragt,
von Polygon.
Und Metriken
zurückliefert, nämlich
letzter Block,
Datum
und, ja,
Zeit
vergangen
seit letzter Block.
Du willst deinen Timeout haben? Okay.
Ähm, Timeout.
Sorry for Bash, danke schön für den Sub.
Excellent.
Very nice.
Und deswegen,
ja,
habe ich letztens, bin ich
zufälligerweise drüber gestolpert,
ist das die Programmiersprache, die so einen komischen
komischen Pipe-Operator
hat, wo ich
gesagt habe, der ist,
der sieht super hässlich aus?
Ja, ist das okay?
So, ich
untime
oute euch mal.
Wieder.
String erinnern, sehr gute Einwand.
Excellent.
Ja.
Ist das nicht, ist das nicht irgendwas in Erlang?
Gleam? Oder wie das heißt?
War das nicht auf Erlang-Basis?
Ah, okay. Chat, bevor wir
anfangen, hat man verstanden, was ich
machen will? Also im Endeffekt
will ich, will ich ein
Prometheus-Exporter bauen, der Kasten Metriken
von uns abfragt,
und dann, äh, ja,
dann, dann bauen wir ein Docker-Image
drinnen, wobei ganz ehrlich weiß ich, ob ich das heute mache.
Also Kasten, Kasten
Metrik-Exporter in Go.
Ich habe das mir vor
Urzeiten schon mal angeguckt, also in
.NET habe ich es schon oft gemacht,
in Go habe ich mir das vor Urzeiten mal angeguckt,
habe aber vergessen, wie es funktioniert.
Das heißt, da müssen wir uns jetzt mal irgendwie
was raussuchen.
OpenTelemetry
oder, oder Golang
Prometheus, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, nach was man da
gescheit suchen muss.
Ja, also, folgender
Plan, folgender Plan.
Wir haben ein Deployment, ein
Kubernetes-Deployment, da ist
das ganze Blockchain-Zeug drinnen, da sind aktuell
zwei Container in einem
Pott, und da kommt jetzt noch ein dritter
Sidecar-Container dabei, der die
Metriken bereitstellt.
Der fragt, macht ein paar API-Abrufe
gegen Localhost dann, weil er ist ja quasi
im gleichen IP
Bereich drinnen.
Der macht
dann ein paar API-Abfragen gegen Localhost,
gegen den eigentlichen Blockchain-Node,
und
daraus generiert er dann drei, vier Metriken,
je nachdem, was wir alles brauchen, und stellt das bereit,
sodass Prometheus das ganze crawlen kann.
So machen wir das.
Was nutzt ihr für die Visualisierung der Metriken,
Grafana?
Ja, auch,
das Ding ist,
wie gesagt, ich arbeite ja bei einer Versicherung, und die sind
zu, das ist so nervig, was dort
an
Netzwerk-Restriktionen ist. Das ist immer alles
ein Riesenakt, bis irgendwas funktioniert.
Das heißt, wir verwenden Grafana,
dort, wo es geht, und dort, wo es noch
ewig dauert, bis alles freigeschaltet ist,
verwenden wir so lange das Google
Cloud, also die Dashboards, die man in
Google Cloud erstellen kann. Ich finde das
extrem hakelig, lahm und
nervig, die Google Cloud-Dashboards.
Das ist wirklich so ein Grafana
very light, aber
bis Grafana da hinkommt und alles collecten
kann, erstmal damit.
Ja. Das finde ich sehr
nice. Vielleicht wirst du ja irgendwann
auch mal zum IT-Guy,
weil der Quereinstieg ist aktuell
so gut wie noch nie möglich,
und außerdem werden händeringend Leute gesucht,
und man kann auch noch eine Ausbildung machen,
wenn man 30 plus ist, gar kein Problem.
So, also das ist das,
was wir heute vorhaben.
Ich starte mal kurz meine Go-Idee.
Ja.
Ich musste auch letztens wieder,
ich hab letztens den Fehler gemacht,
wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben?
Monks, das ist ja
AI Assistant, nein, nein, nein,
ich geh mal, geh mal weg. Go Land.
Geh weg. So.
Ja, das ist nochmal new.
Wir machen mal kurz, wir machen mal kurz
ein neues Verzeichnis.
Gpos,
mkdir, wie nennen wir das Ding?
Äh.
Immer ein guter Name.
Block.
Crypto, ne.
Block. Chain.
Monitor.
Irgendwie so.
So nennen wir das.
Go Land. Punkt.
Bam.
Ja, ja, wir trusten dem Project.
Gar kein Problem.
Das ist gar kein Project.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Ich bin immer, wenn ich lange nichts in Go gemacht hab,
bin ich immer verwirrt, wie das funktioniert.
Wartet mal,
man muss ja, man sagt, new
Project.
So, und jetzt, äh,
Blockchain, nicht Black, Black Chain.
Come on, bra.
Blockchain
Monitor Champ, da wollen wir hin.
Und
ist das jetzt, ist das jetzt standardmäßig ein
Go-Modules-Projekt? Ich glaube schon.
By the way, ich checke nicht,
was das hier macht. Was macht das?
Ah ja, meinetwegen.
Äh. Was?
Das ist überhaupt kein Projekt
drinne.
Alter.
Will ich verarschen?
Da ist doch überhaupt nichts drinne, alter.
Was ist das hier?
Oder?
Was drinne?
Ach, da ist der IDE-Ordner drinne.
Alter, PPGA Jetbrains.
Wie erhebst du eigentlich Metriken?
Ja, also, für den?
Ich raste hier aus, ey. Kann das mal funktionieren
jetzt, please?
Jetzt hat er das wieder geöffnet. Ich muss das schon wieder löschen.
Ja.
Ähm.
In dem Fall
mache ich ein paar Abfragen
gegen die API von dem eigentlichen Service.
Rechne ein bisschen was mit dem Datum
aus.
Und dann exportiere ich das als
Prometheus-Metriken
in das Window.
Okay, jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Okay, das ist auch
ein Go-Modules-Projekt.
Okay.
Sehr schön. Sehr schön.
Also, welcher Service?
Ach so, was wir da verwenden.
Das kann ich tatsächlich zeigen,
weil das ist ein Open-Source-Projekt.
Wir verwenden da
das da.
Das ist eine Ethereum-
Implementierung, aber das kann ganz viele
verschiedene Blockchains.
Unter anderem Polygon.
Guck, steht ja auch hier Polygon.
Guck, Knossi
kann das auch.
Und das Ding bietet eine API an.
Und die API werde ich abfragen.
Also, ich hole mir raus.
Letzter Block.
Ich mach mal kurz hier
go-file-main.go
Ja, also
ich muss mir dann rausholen.
Warte mal, wie war das in Go?
Was? Letzter Block?
Letzter Block?
Letzter Block
ID
oder so.
Wobei, das haben wir ja schon.
Letzter Block ID.
Letzter Block
Datum oder Timestamp.
Timestamp
und
Letzter Block
Ja, äh
nicht Timestamp
Zeit
oder wie alt.
Also quasi aktuelle Zeit minus
die Zeit
von hier.
Das sind die drei Metriken, die wir erstmal exportieren wollen.
Und ich muss jetzt gucken, wie man in Go
einen eigenen Prometheus
Exporter baut.
Hat jemand schon sowas gemacht?
Also ich vermute mal, dass OpenTelemetry
und irgendwelche Prometheus
Libraries da gute Anlaufpunkte sind.
Übrigens, GoInit
und gut. Macht das dann auch
mittlerweile standardmäßig ein Modules-Projekt
und nervt nicht mehr rum mit GoPath?
Welche IDE ist
das? Das ist GoLand.
JetBrains.
JetBrains GoLand.
Was auch immer.
Find ich nice.
Es tun auch andere
IDEs. Ja, du kannst auch Visual Studio
Code nehmen mit dem GoPlugin oder
manche Verrückten benutzen auch
NeoWim.
Das Ding ist, ich hab das
All IDE Package.
Das heißt, ich wär blöd, wenn ich's nicht verwende.
Und die Dinger taugen von denen auch. Ich benutze nicht
alles von denen. Also ich benutze,
also die haben ja hier, guck mal hier,
JetBrains, die haben ja tausend
Dinger. Ja, die haben
was für Ruby, die haben...
Guck mal, die haben...
Genau, die haben IntelliJ.
IntelliJ kennt wahrscheinlich
das kennen die wahrscheinlich die meisten.
Das ist für die ganzen Java-Enjoyer
unter uns. Es gibt glaube ich auch
IntelliJ Premium oder sowas
in der Richtung, gell? Kann das sein?
Oder ist das nur
bei Visual Studio so? Also
IntelliJ für die ganzen
Java-Enjoyer.
PyCharm, PHPStorm,
wer es braucht, GoLand, Rider,
C-Line, RubyMine, hab ich früher ab und zu mal
verwendet. Rustro haben wir auch schon benutzt.
Also von den IDEs, von denen verwende
ich PyCharm ab und zu mal.
Du hast bestimmt 10 JetBrains IDEs.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen blöd,
dass es nicht so ein Universal-Ding
gibt, das stimmt schon. Ich mein, mit Fleet wollen sie
ja, aber ich seh's aktuell noch nicht.
Die brauchen halt auch RAM
as Fuck und Speicher, aber hauptsächlich RAM.
Also ich verwende von denen
ab und zu mal PyCharm. PyCharm
gibt's auch in irgendeiner Professional-Variante.
Ich hab bis heute nicht gecheckt, was der Unterschied
zwischen der freien und der Professional-Variante ist.
Ich verwende das ab und zu relativ selten.
Das verwende ich häufiger.
Das verwende ich sehr oft.
Das verwende ich auch ab und zu.
Selten, weil ich selten was in Rust
mache, aber das haben wir auch schon ausprobiert.
RubyMine so gut wie gar nicht mehr, hab ich früher öfters
verwendet.
Und...
Das war's.
Deswegen hab ich mir auch das All Desktop Package gekauft.
Und das Zeug taugt echt.
Also ich mag
die Chatbrand-Sachen,
obwohl das auf Java-Basis ist.
Alles.
Also ich programmiere quasi
Go jetzt mit der Hilfe von
Java.
Wie das die coolen Leute sagen.
Hier gibt's nen Vergleich.
Oh, es gibt vor allem
Plant-Granate.
Wat?
Kann das mal please...
Meine Augen, man.
Also. Ja gut.
Die ganzen Languages jucken mich null.
Das ist auch...
Dafür bin...
Also ganz ehrlich, für Frontend bin ich auf
Visual Studio Code hängengeblieben.
Ich könnte natürlich auch mit Dings
WebStorm verwenden, mach ich aber nicht.
Für Frontend verwende ich tatsächlich
was anderes
als Chatbrand-Sachen.
Also ich seh da keinen großen
Vorteil.
Ich mein Perforce
oder Perforce, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Benutzt das überhaupt irgendjemand?
Wie sieht dein PS1
im Terminal aus?
Was?
DarkRef, ich weiß legit nicht, was du meinst.
Ist PS1 PowerShell?
Ich benutze keine
PowerShell, das ist Linux.
Das ist ZSH.
Nicht PowerShell.
Da würde ich ja...
Krämpfe bekommen, wenn ich PowerShell
benutzen muss hier.
Das stimmt, die schnellsten IDEs sind das nicht.
Aber wenn die Sachen erstmal geladen sind, voll...
Okay. PowerShell ist gar nicht
so schlimm. Doch, ich finde PowerShell
ist schlimm. Als interaktive Shell
finde ich PowerShell ganz grausam.
Also ich mein, alles ist besser als
Batch. Hat jemand mal die
Ehre, ja, mit Windows...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Standard-Shell
heißt von Windows, die man mit
CMD aufmacht. Heißt die auch CMD? Heißt die
Batch? Batch ist die
Scripting-Sprache...
Das ist natürlich super
extrem, also
die größte Scheiße, die es gibt.
PowerShell ist ganz
okay, im Vergleich dazu.
Aber PowerShell, finde ich, ist keine gute
interaktive Shell. PowerShell ist dafür
extrem nice zum Automatisieren für
Windows-Sachen. Übrigens, Leute,
Microsoft
hat wieder zugeschlagen. Wusstet
ihr...
Wusstet ihr, dass
Microsoft Office
für Server deprecated
ist? Okay, findet man gar nicht
in den News. Microsoft
supportet offiziell bald nicht
mehr Office auf Servern.
Fragt mich nicht, warum es Leute
gibt, die Microsoft Office auf Servern installiert
haben, aber das wird nicht mehr supportet
von Microsoft. Ach,
das meinst du. Du meinst dein...
Du meinst dein Command-Prompt.
Okay.
Jetzt, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Der sieht
nicht so aus,
wie du dir das vorstellst.
Ich benutze Starship.
Starship generiert das on the fly dynamisch.
Und das passiert hier drinne.
Da.
Starship
Starship setzt den Prompt quasi.
Wenn man das hier ausführt,
dann siehst du hier, guck,
was Starship macht.
Das will man aber nicht.
Die Shell ist
quasi, wird dynamisch generiert
von Starship.
Und Starship ist natürlich der beste Prompt,
weil, ihr seht es schon
an der Domain,
Blazingly fast written in Rust.
Das kann oberst taugen.
Ich hab
ein bisschen was customised da dran.
Wenn du, wenn du genau wissen willst,
was ich customised habe, kannst du hier meine
.files gucken. Da ist was drinne hier.
.config
Starship.
Hier siehst du die Config für mein Prompt.
Ich hab eigentlich nur
das default Theme ein bisschen angepasst.
Oder eines der, der mitgelieferten
Themes ein bisschen angepasst.
Die, die Farben
ein bisschen besser lesbar gemacht.
Und
ich glaub noch ein paar Infos hinzugefügt
für C-Sharp Projekte.
Für .net Projekte.
Und das wars. Mehr hab ich nicht gemacht.
Kennst du das von Arch,
Arch Linux by the way?
Ich use, ich use by the way
auch Arch. Ich dachte mir, ich erwähne
das mal. Weil alle coolen
Leute Arch verwenden. By the way.
Was ist mit Terminal Server?
Tja, weiß ich nicht. Da ist es wahrscheinlich
noch okay.
Habe ich heute gehört auf der Arbeit.
Microsoft supportet kein Office mehr auf
Windows Server.
Das erste, was ich mir gedacht habe ist, was?
Es gibt wirklich paar Verrückte,
die nicht nur Windows Server einsetzen, sondern auch
wirklich Office da drauf installiert haben.
Denkt ihr Programmierkenntnisse werden
künftig mehr oder weniger
absurd? Nein, Quatsch.
Das glaube ich nicht. Es gab schon so ein paar Trends.
Eines der letzten Trends war
diese ganze Low Code, No Code Geschichte.
Die im Endeffekt eigentlich noch dazu führt,
dass du eher noch mehr brauchst
an Entwicklern, die das quasi
dann so bauen, dass
Noobs es wieder können. Ich halte
übrigens von den meisten No Code, Low Code
Sachen überhaupt gar nichts.
Und
ich glaube auch nicht, dass uns
Machine Learning irgendwie
ersetzen wird. Es wird
auf jeden Fall als Unterstützung
wichtiger werden, aber
du wirst keine Programmierer ersetzen mit
Machine Learning. Ich glaube sogar eher,
genau, ich glaube sogar eher,
dass, weil viele mehr auf KI
aufspringen, ist es natürlich nicht verkehrt, sich ein bisschen damit
auszukennen. Und ich gehe
davon aus, dass sich sogar kurzfristig eher mehr Leute
suchen werden, weil der Bereich noch dazu
gekommen ist. Ja, sad
girl, sad girl. Schlimm, oder?
Ich kann beruflich kein Windows,
äh, kein, ha, das wäre schön.
Ich kann beruflich kein Linux verwenden.
Also, das stimmt nicht. Ich verdiene mit Linux
auch beruflich mein Geld.
Aber
auf meinem Notebook,
also auf meinem
quasi meiner Workstation,
kann ich kein Linux verwenden.
Weil da muss ich das offizielle
Image von der Firma verwenden,
wo erstmal 75 Security Tools laufen.
Und das ist so schlimm, das ist
ein richtig fetter Laptop, irgendwie 8 Kerne,
32 GB RAM, aber der ist
echt so krass langsam
durch dieses ganze Security Zeug,
da drehst du echt ab.
Schlimm. Übrigens,
ich muss gerade, ich muss gerade nochmal was loswerden, Leute.
Twitter hat mich wieder echt super
verwirrt die letzten Tage, ne.
Ich darf noch ein bisschen Zeit getrackt werden,
weil die Stunde ist noch nicht um, okay?
Es ist mir, es fällt mir gerade so ein, ey.
Twitter hat mich wieder
echt mal wieder, ich hab, ich hab
die letzten Tage auf Twitter wieder realisiert,
warum
meine Heimat auf Twitter Andorra
ist. Da muss man sich nämlich die
Deutschen, beziehungsweise so die
ganzen größeren internationalen Trends
nicht angucken. In Andorra kommt das nicht an.
Die einzigen Sachen, die in Andorra
trenden, sind ab und zu mal
Andorra selbst, wo ich
nicht genau weiß, warum. Und manchmal
trendet Tour de France, wenn
die nach Andorra fährt. Ansonsten
trendet auf Twitter in Andorra legit
nichts. Ich habe keine Trends
in Andorra. Was sehr gut
ist, was sehr gut ist.
Twitter-Trends, gerade die deutschen Twitter-Trends,
ey, du flippst aus im Kopf.
Letztens
hab ich gesehen, hat getrendet
Blutbad. Und da hab ich
mir erst mal gedacht, alter, irgendjemand
Amok gelaufen wieder, oder was, was
ist gewesen?
Und dann kommt raus, da hat Trump
irgendeine komische Pepega-Rede gehalten
und alle haben sich super krass
reingesteigert wieder.
Und sind da eskaliert auf Twitter,
alter. Wo ich immer denke,
haben die alle sonst überhaupt
gar keine Probleme mehr? Ist denen ihre Zeit
echt nicht zu schade dafür?
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Die haben sich so krass reingesteigert
wieder. Ich hab mir den
Clip angeguckt, ja,
und hab mir gedacht, okay,
ich mein, ist halt,
bisschen scharfe Rhetorik.
So what?
Hat mich so null tangiert, was der, der hat schon so
viel komisches Zeug erzählt.
Ja, okay, so what? Next.
Du steigerst dich in
Twitch rein. Ja, auf Twitch reinsteigern find ich auch
nice. Aber auf Twitter versteh ich das nicht.
Es war super
aus, ja, du hast recht, es war super aus
dem Kontext gerissen. Was auch
so ein Ding, Gegenbeispiel, ja.
Es lassen sich auf Twitter, egal welche, welche
Seite, es gibt ja nicht nur zwei Seiten, es gibt ja
gefühlt unendlich viele
Seiten auf Twitter,
die sich gerne
die Köpfe einschlagen. Es ist
letztens auch in Deutschland, es war ein deutscher Trend
auf Twitter, Ratten ist getrendet.
Da hat unser Bundespräsident
in irgendeiner Rede erzählt, irgendwas
von Rattenfängern. Der hat nicht gesagt, dass die
Wähler Ratten sind. Und
da kam dann die,
die ganzen Verschwörungstheorie-Leute und rechten
Leute kamen dann an, der Bundespräsident
bezeichnet alle als Ratten.
Der hat mir den Ausschnitt angeguckt,
denkt mir so, Alter, ihr glaubt
auch, dass Zitronenfalter Zitronen
falten, oder?
Wenn man das wörtlich nimmt. Das hat er
überhaupt nicht gesagt.
Ja klar, der hat
die, der hat
die als Rattenfänger bezeichnet,
aber damit ist doch eindeutig gemeint,
so nach dem Motto, genau das
hat er gesagt, damit ist doch eindeutig gemeint,
dass er
also was er sagen möchte ist,
die labert viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, auf gut
Deutsch. Wie man das, wie man
dort auf die Idee kommen kann, das
wörtlich zu nehmen, verstehe ich nicht.
Ich mein, Chat, Chat, ja?
Wenn der Chat mal wieder so richtig pepega Chatting
betreibt, und ich sag Chat,
ihr seid aber heute ganz schön hirnlos,
was ich nicht sage, weil mein Chat ist natürlich
high IQ und schlau, und durch jeden Sub
steigt der Durchschnitts-IQ, aber angenommen,
ich sage Chat, ihr seid ja heute wieder ganz schön
hirnlos, damit meine ich doch nicht
wörtlich, dass ihr
in eurem Schädel keine Gehirnmasse
habt. Ich mein, damit
ihr seid heute ganz schön blöd.
Bei manchen bin ich mir da nicht so sicher,
bei manchen kann das schon sein, ja? Gerade auf Twitter.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, Alter, wie kann man das
wörtlich nehmen? Und gestern oder so, wann das war,
als ich diesen Trend gelesen hab
mit Blutbad zu Trump,
erste, was ich bei sowas mache, ist immer, ich guck mir mal
den Clip an, guck ich mir den Clip an,
und denk mir danach so,
ja, so what?
Also,
er hat ja eigentlich gar nichts Wildes
gesagt. Er hat Sinn, also
für alle, die den Clip nicht gesehen haben,
er hat sinngemäß gesagt, also er hat das Wort
Blutbad ist gefallen, aber in einem komplett anderen
Kontext. Der hat sinngemäß gesagt,
die Chinesen, oder ich glaub, die Chinesen waren's,
die Chinesen wären ja in Mexiko,
und, äh,
der wird
dafür sorgen, dass die da keinen Fuß fassen
können, die Chinesen in Mexiko,
und dass, wenn er am Start ist,
wird das alles super krass besteuert,
und, ähm,
wenn,
wenn er gewählt wird, oder,
oder nur wenn er gewählt wird,
bringt er das in Ordnung,
dass die Chinesen da in Mexiko hier nicht
irgendwie ihre Dinger treiben können, aber,
aber wenn er nicht gewählt wird,
dann gibt das ein Blutbad. So, das hat er gesagt.
Wie man da wortwörtlich drauf
kommen kann, dass es ein Blutbad
im wörtlichen Sinne gibt,
ey, keine Ahnung.
Ich versteh nicht,
was mit den Leuten los ist. Du musst dir einfach nur
eine Minute dreißig Clip angucken,
und du weißt sofort, ey, nix dran!
Und ich bin, ich bin schon,
ich bin schon gespannt,
was da noch kommt. Ich mein,
dass der Kerl öfters mal Blödsinn erzählt,
ich sag bloß,
Desinfektionsmittel trinken bei Corona,
und sowas,
ne, da müssen wir nicht von reden, in dem Fall
war halt nichts irgendwie
im, im wörtlichen Sinne da rein
zu interpretieren, deswegen
konnte ich, konnte ich die ganze Aufregung
nicht verstehen. Und das waren jetzt zwei
Beispiele, die mir so spontan eingefallen sind,
so mit, mit den Ratten und dem Blutbad,
wo man wieder sieht, da wird sich einfach nur
ein Wort rausgepickt,
was ohne Kontext
einfach nur halt
heftig so klingt, aber
was, wenn du dir das beim Näher betrachtest,
so gar nix Wildes dran ist.
Oh ne, wie flippen wir immer aus!
Und ich denk mir dann immer so, man,
Leute, habt ihr echt nix
irgendwie in eurem Leben anderes zu tun,
wo ihr euch Sorgen drüber machen müsst?
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Ist egal, ist auch genug Zeit getrackt,
das Programmieren will go, ich bin 50 Minuten Zeit getrackt.
Ah,
ich versteh die Welt dann teilweise echt nicht.
So,
jetzt wird go, go geproggert.
Also,
wir wollen,
wir machen einen Prometheus-Exporter
in go, hab ich noch nie gemacht. Wie macht man einen
Prometheus-Exporter? Also, doch, hab ich
schon mal mir vor Jahren angeguckt.
So, chat,
wie würdet ihr, wirklich,
Twitter hältst du nicht länger aus.
Chat, wie würdet ihr heute einen Prometheus-Exporter
machen in go?
Mit irgendwelchen OpenTelemetry
Lips oder mit einer
dedizierten
Prometheus-Library?
OpenTelemetry ist ja, würd ich sagen,
prinzipiell eher sinnvoll,
wenn man ne Anwendung hat
und daraus Metriken exportieren will
und vielleicht nicht nur Metriken für Prometheus,
sondern auch, äh,
Logs oder in einem anderen Format
und sowas. Ja, ne, mit Standard-Lip
kannst du, kannst du schon mal vergessen.
Ja. Wie macht man
denn einen Prometheus? Zeig mal hier.
Prometheus, Prometheus, Library
for go. Ja.
Nice. Examples.
Exemplars.
Ist ihm noch nicht aufgefallen,
in den letzten
zwei Jahren,
dass sein Ordner falsch heißt.
Simple. Simple klingt gut.
Simple finde ich nice.
Okay.
Also, was, was brauchen wir?
Klein Golang.
Prometheus, Prometheus,
BromHTTP.
Flag, String,
Listen.
Was? Registry?
Collectors? What?
Also, ich muss sagen,
die .NET Prometheus Library ist schon
ein bisschen pepeger zu bedienen.
Aber was bin ich denn hier sehend?
Und wir gucken uns mal, wir gucken uns mal kurz
ein OpenTelemetry Beispiel an, okay?
Examples.
Prometheus.
Oder wie die Amis sagen,
Die sind aber auch nicht mehr ganz dicht, was sowas angeht.
Genau, die sagen ja auch nicht
Beteigeuze, sondern Beetlejuice.
Letztens
hat wirklich ernsthaft jemand,
mit dem ich im Discord geschwätzt hab,
hat nicht DHL gesetzt.
Das ist Deutscher, ja. Genau.
Der hat nicht DHL gesagt, der hat ernsthaft
gesagt, bei DHL.
Da muss ich erst mal kurz überlegen,
meint der jetzt DHL?
Oder meint der jetzt
was anderes, was zufälligerweise genauso
abgekürzt wird? Aber nein, der meint wirklich DHL.
DHL.
Ist doch richtig.
Warum ist das richtig?
Und wenn du mir jetzt kommst mit,
dass das eigentlich ne, frag mich
nicht, ne
US Firma, ich weiß es gar nicht,
wo die gegründet wurde, ja, hast du
recht, ist aber vollkommen
irrelevant in dem Fall.
Wir haben uns hier drauf geeinigt, dass es
DHL heißt, jeder sagt DHL und
DHL selber
sagt in Deutschland DHL.
Übrigens, Amazon hat
auch in ihrer Werbung früher gesagt
Amazon. Mittlerweile
sind sie auch schon bei, bei Emerson.
Aber es kommt, aber
und außerdem, und außerdem ist
Emerson hört sich irgendwie noch
ganz okay an, aber DHL
wir können nur froh sein,
dass kein W
in DHL ist. Stellt euch mal vor, das würde
keine Ahnung, äh
DWL oder so heißen.
Dann würde es DWL
heißen, noch schlimmer. Man muss ja, also
ganz ehrlich, W
ist, ist glaube ich der, der größte
pepega Buchstabe, den es gibt.
Die, die, die Amis, ja,
also wir sagen HTTP,
also wir sagen www.google.de
und die Amis müssen
wirklich sagen WWL.
www.google.de
Also, das ist
so hängen geblieben, da fällt
mir echt nichts mehr zu ein. Deswegen
ignoriere ich jegliche Abkürzung
mit W drinne.
Ja WTF ist auch
sowas. WTF ist
schön auszusprechen, ja,
aber WTF
ne, oh guck mal
es gibt Documentation, ah.
Das sind, Leute,
das ist mein Mann,
der das hier erstellt hat.
Es gibt keine Documentation,
der ist Wubbler Certified,
der weiß wie es geht, es funktioniert einfach.
Der Code dokumentiert sich selbst.
Ja, das werden wir jetzt mal überprüfen,
inwieweit sich der Code selbst dokumentiert.
Zeigt mal her.
Wie, wie, wie selbst
dokumentiert sich der Code?
const metaname
Ich hab ernsthaft
keine Ahnung, was diese Syntax in Go
bedeutet.
const metaname
Ist das ein Link zu Github?
What?
Was ist das?
Ist das sowas wie ein Export?
Ein Rename von einem Export in
JavaScript?
Dass man nicht will, dass das ganze irgendwie
konfliktet?
Ne, Moment, examples?
Okay, absolut kein Plastenschimmer, was die wollen.
Was das bedeuten soll.
New Source
New Meta
Provider
Boah, das ist ja ne Wissens...
Alter!
What the fuck?
Das ist ja ne Wissenschaft für sich.
Meta.float64ObservableGauch
Okay, das kommt mir ein bisschen...
Also, mal ganz im Ernst.
Die .NET Library ist schon nicht schön.
Für
Prometheus, ja?
Und die Beispiele sind
noch beschissener.
Ja, aber
die sieht besser aus als das.
Wo kommt
Meta her?
Wahrscheinlich hier.
Okay, Moment, wir brauchen mal...
Wir nehmen mal das.
Also, wie funsten das Ganze?
Gibt es vielleicht auch eine nicht-simple
Exemplars?
Nehmen wir jetzt mal.
Main Goal.
Okay, hier ist ein bisschen mehr drin.
Also,
Requestorations, New Histogram,
Create Registry,
Add Go Runtime Matrix
and Provide Collectors.
Nee, Go Runtime Matrix
können wir exportieren.
Why not? Schadet nichts.
Kostet Geld, wenn man es bei Google speichert.
Das ist quasi eine Endlosschleife
mit einem Sleep, die die Werte
updatet. Okay, das check ich.
Okay, ich nehme das zurück.
Ist doch halbwegs simpel, oder?
Probieren wir nochmal.
Also, dann importieren wir mal das Ganze.
Nee, Moment.
Package muss Main heißen,
sonst funzt es ja nicht.
Was, sind die Cola dahinter?
Nee.
Was ist das für ein Problem jetzt?
Ach, Moment, da muss Import
davor. Ich kack Noob.
Import.
Lul.
Warum ist das weg?
Ach so, weil Go wieder am nerven ist.
Go ist wieder am nerven,
weil ich die Dinger nirgendswo verwende.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Das sind so kleine Dinger,
die mich übelst abfacken.
Nee, wahrscheinlich
muss ich die nicht manuell importieren,
mache ich aber gerne, weil ich dann direkt Autocomplete habe.
Okay, mit Prometheus
kann man irgendwas an...
Jetzt ist er schon wieder weg. Bleibst du mal da?
Es downloadet übrigens noch.
Du musst nur
Go get link, dann macht er das selber.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
was der dann selber macht, auf was sich das jetzt
bezieht.
Kannst du das einfach Go mod tidy machen
und was passiert dann?
Die Imports macht er dann selber.
Wie jetzt?
Äh, vor allem...
Warum? Ist er jetzt fertig, oder?
Unused
Import, okay.
Warum erkennt er jetzt
nicht? Konnte man nicht irgendwie sowas
davor machen, dass er es dann ignoriert?
Das ist auch, das ist auch so ein
Go-Magic-Ding, äh.
Sollte ich nicht so... Ach, Moment,
ich brauch Function main.
Function main.
Und jetzt kann ich das machen.
Pro...
Prometheus, da ist es.
So, wie geht es jetzt? Prometheus
new, Prometheus...
äh, new?
Counter.
Counter ist schon mal okay, ja.
So, Hilfe, Hilfetexte
sind overrated, outdated,
jebaited.
Dann werden die Imports gedownloadet.
Hat er doch schon gemacht, gerade.
Ja, aber ich will ja Autocomplete haben.
Also, so scheint das ja schon mal zu funzen.
Wir müssen übrigens mal ein Terminal aufmachen.
Machen wir das ohne, machen wir das rechts.
Ich mach das hier hin. Chatge, ich weiß,
es kann sein, ihr müsst mich dran erinnern,
wenn ihr jetzt gleich nichts sehen solltet,
weil manchmal backt das ja immer ein bisschen rum,
hier unten mit dem Chat.
Ein bisschen breiter, das machen wir weg.
Wir machen das so, dass ich, äh...
Oh, bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie...
Moment. Ähm...
Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt gescheit
angeordnet?
Wie können die drei Skills failen?
Wie kriege ich das gescheit gesplittet
auf der rechten Seite jetzt?
Gar nicht.
Ich bilde mir eigentlich ein, dass ich das so machen müsste,
aber das funzt nicht.
Egal.
Dann machen wir einfach so.
Repos...
Go, run.
Nee, nicht godrun.
So, Punkt.
Oh je, ja.
Es hat funktioniert.
Kackt schon mal nicht komplett ab.
Also, wie funktioniert das?
Was macht der Typ jetzt?
Registry, create non-global registry.
Okay, whatever.
Keine Ahnung, wofür es gut ist, aber machen wir mal.
Registry must register.
Ich copy-paste
mir einfach mal das Beispiel.
Collect your new go-collector,
new process...
Okay, es...
New process collector
returns a
collector, which exports the current state
of process metrics, including
CPU, memory and file descriptor
usage as well as process start time.
Alles klar.
Das heißt,
jetzt habe ich die basic matrix.
Gucken wir uns das doch mal an, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Das brauchen wir nicht und jetzt brauchen wir hier
handle...
Okay, nice.
Einfach rein copy-paste
und hoffen, dass es funzt.
Ja.
Einfach so einen Curl machen, oder? Man braucht nicht...
Oh, Matrix-Text da reinschreiben.
Okay, go, run.
Alles klar.
So, das heißt, wir sollten jetzt
eigentlich lokal auf port
8080 was laufen haben.
Curl local host
port 8080 slash geht nicht
slash matrix.
Da ist es doch. Nice.
Okay, wir haben schon ein paar Standardmetriken exportiert,
die keine Sau je
auswerten wird.
Aber ich wollte einfach nur gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Nee, Leute.
Ich exportiere die
Standardmetriken nicht.
Wobei...
Chat, was meint ihr?
Soll ich die Standardmetriken exportieren
oder nicht? Mein Gedanke ist ja erstmal,
eigentlich braucht diese
Standardmetriken niemand. Aber,
aber, pass mal auf,
aber...
Stellt euch mal vor,
wir lassen das jetzt
in einem Container laufen
und wir geben dem Container,
weil das ja quasi nur so ein minimaler
Hilfscontainer ist für Metriken,
dem gebe ich irgendwie
ein sechzehntel
CPU in Kubernetes
und 64 MB RAM
und wir haben irgendwann mal
Probleme und die Metriken werden nicht richtig collected.
So könnte ich tatsächlich sehen, dass mein Prozess
immer mal wieder
an die Speichergrenze kommt
oder irgendwelche Probleme hat.
Anderweitig nicht.
Was exportiert er denn?
Was...
Was ist das?
Enable Open Metriks.
Dann machen wir mal
das hier kurz weg
und gucken mal, was er dann alles exportiert.
Das ist aber...
Das müllt, ganz ehrlich,
das müllt eigentlich nur unnötig den Export
voll. Ich glaube, ich lasse das weg.
Ich glaube, ich lasse das weg.
Ich glaube,
ich lasse das weg.
Ja, jetzt...
Jetzt respondet er halt mit einer leeren Seite.
Genau.
Okay, und wie kriege ich da jetzt
Metriken rein?
Ich mach mal kurz die Schrift einen Ticken kleiner.
So, wie kriege ich da jetzt
Metriken rein?
Was mit R kannst du Auto reloaden
und Change sparst dir dann jedes Mal
Go-Run. Das ist cool, dass sowas wie
.NET Watch mit...
Wie heißt das? R?
R? Golang.
R?
Live Reload for Go Apps.
Tatsächlich.
14,7 Tausend
Sterne, krass.
Live Reload for Go Apps.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Ach, das macht im Endeffekt einfach
nur ein Watch drauf.
Was ist Goblin Run schon
wieder?
Die haben echt alle ein bisschen den Arsch offen, ey.
Golang Binary
in a Curl, Build by Goblins.
Alles klar. Weißt sofort, was
das Projekt macht, oder? Wir...
Wir curlen random irgendwelche Sachen
aus dem Internet und pipen sie in ne Shell.
Das ist eindeutig
de weh.
Go Install. Ich geh mal davon aus, ich hab
die Sachen gar nicht in meinem
Path drinne. Ich weiß nicht,
was... Ich weiß nicht, was
Go Install jetzt überhaupt... Wow.
Okay, erst mal 30.000
Sachen... Ist das jetzt installiert? Nee.
Wo installiert Go denn
überhaupt was hin?
Ah, ah, okay, da gibts...
Oh, Go installiert noch Go.
Die haben auch
keinen Bock, das Verzeichnis irgendwie zu verstecken
oder so, gell? Das juckt
die nicht. Also kann ich jetzt quasi
nach Go Bin Air
gehen und dann
einfach Punkt oder so?
Ah...
Okay, jetzt ändere ich
hier mal was. Äh...
Äh...
Matrix...
Ach ja!
Nice, gefällt
mir. Hat was. Hat was. Hat was.
Excellent.
Das ist der Chat. Deswegen mag ich euch. Ihr seid
so high IQ, was das angeht.
So, und jetzt checkt er auch, dass
er's restarten muss. Running.
Ja, ja, ja. Macht er. Macht er.
Curl. Curl. Matrix.
Funst. Matrix.
Restart.
Not found. Geht.
Cool.
Das ist ein nices Projekt. Das gefällt
mir. Chico... Chico
guckt auch ganz begeistert.
Okay, wie exportiere ich denn jetzt
hier was? Also, must register.
Da, da geht das doch irgendwie
drüber.
Also hier, requesterations.
Der legt hier was an. Aha.
Aha, so funst das. Also.
Also, brauche ich quasi sowas
wie... Nennen wir's mal,
nennen wir's mal hier irgendwie
äh, last block
oder so. Ja?
Ach ne, Moment. Doppelpunkt gleich.
Weil, weil go.
Jetzt sagt er not in use. Ja, ist gut.
Ist gut.
Und jetzt, new registry und
dann, ach hier, einfach reinschreiben.
Was jetzt?
Too many arguments.
Ach ne,
must register musst du's rein.
Äh.
Is invalid. Is not a valid metric name.
Okay, name. Name
von der metric
is, ja, last block.
Gibt das, gibt das eine naming convention
für Matrix mit Underscore
glaub ich, gell?
Prometheus, Prometheus, Metric
naming convention.
Ja, mit Underscore, genau.
Also heißt das Ding
last block
curl
not found. Guck, last block
null. Nice, wir kriegen...
Das ist, okay, da habe ich am Anfang
echt zu Unrecht drüber geflamed, dass das
kompliziert aussieht. Bis jetzt finde ich
das eigentlich sehr kurz, knackig und nice.
Das, das hat was.
Okay, was ist, was ist
up system und namespace?
Keckel.
Const labels.
Okay, help ist das da?
Was ist das?
Ist das normalerweise nicht immer in
in geschweiften Klammern dahinter,
wenn man die gleiche Metrik hat für verschiedene
ja, ähm, verschiedene
wie nennt man das dann?
Einheiten?
Oder mache ich das mit labels in dem Fall
dann?
Const labels?
Jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich überfragt
wie das funzt.
Was?
Was will der hier von mir?
Er will, äh, wir bauen einen
Prometheus-Exporter
in Go. Und ich habe noch nie
einen Prometheus-Exporter richtig in Kompletten
gebaut in Go. Aber
was will der denn hier überhaupt jetzt
von mir? Ich, da bin ich zu Go-Noob für.
Gucken wir mal
uns die examples an. Hat der da
irgendwas mit const labels drin? Wie muss denn das aus?
Äh
Du hast doch einen Exporter für mehrere
Nodes oder kannst du dann ja Labels?
Ja, ich habe, lass, oh das ist ne gute Frage.
Ich habe
die, das Deployment
potenziell mehrfach drauf, ja.
Das muss ja dann irgendwie Unique sein.
Wobei, das ist schon Unique,
weil es beim Collecten als Label
ja den, den Source mitkriegt
von wo das kommt, also.
Also eigentlich brauche ich gar keine Labels.
Aber mich würde trotzdem interessieren, wie das
äh, funzt. Ne, ich muss mal kurz
ein Beispiel mir angucken.
Da bin ich zu, zu, zu
zu Noob für.
Aha!
So.
So ganz hab ich auch nicht gecheckt.
Okay.
Prometheus Labels Name, also
quasi sowas muss ich da reinmachen.
Name und
das andere ist Value is Kekkel, okay.
So
und jetzt Change Detected.
Jetzt hat das hier.
Ja, naja, okay, okay.
Ja.
Gut zu wissen.
Also Subsystem schmeißen wir raus.
Namespace, mein Namespace.
Namespace
and name are complements of the fully
qualified name of the metric.
Only name is mandatory, ja.
Ja, das lassen
wir jetzt erstmal weg.
Help, ja da denken wir uns einen schönen,
schönen Text für aus.
Okay, alles klar. Ja.
Ja, auf uns.
Okay, ähm, dann
heißt das jetzt im Endeffekt,
wenn ich jetzt mal
angenommen, wir faken
jetzt mal, wir faken jetzt mal, dass sich,
dass sich das ändert. Okay.
Das, das heißt wir machen mal so ein
Background, so ein Background
Thread quasi, wie
nennt sich das? Background Go
Routine.
So ging das.
Na, Go Funk
und dann sagen wir While, in den While
Schleife gibt es, ah Moment, es ist ja Go.
Es gibt ja keine While Schleife, es gibt ja nur
For Schleifen.
For True.
Und jetzt setzen wir mal da
irgendwie Counter Increment.
Okay.
Das brauchen wir nicht, einfach nur
For Condition is Redundant.
Äh, Moment, Moment, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Das ist jetzt, das ist eine etwas zu schnelle
Endlosschleife. Wenn ich das jetzt starte,
habe ich instant erstmal
eine CPU voll. Das ist vielleicht nicht so geil.
Aber er updatet, der updatet halt ein bisschen schneller
als notwendig.
Time, Sleep
und das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt diese Go
Geschichte, Duration. Wie ging das nochmal?
Time,
Seconds
und dann quasi so mal
für eine Sekunde, irgendwie so, gell.
Oder mal 2 für 2 Sekunden.
Ah, Milliseconds.
Ne.
Milliseconds
mal
500. Okay, also quasi
jede halbe Sekunde die Metrik
updaten.
Funzt. Wenn ich zu schnell bin,
funzt nicht.
Aber es funzt.
Okay, Metrik wird geupdatet.
Das mag ich echt an Go.
Für so kleinen Kram ist das ziemlich
kurz und
schmerzlos, ja.
So, das updatet die Metrik.
Gut.
Nächster Punkt ist, wir tun jetzt
einfach mal so, was wird gebaut?
Achso, ne, hab ich ja schon beantwortet, gell.
Hab ich schon, ja. Wir bauen Prometheus
Exporter. So, wir tun, wir tun
jetzt einfach mal so, als hätte ich hier den Kram laufen.
Ich brauche übrigens lokal noch nen
Prometheus, um das zu scrapen
und ein Grafana. Das werde ich,
das starte ich einfach irgendwie im Docker
und greif dann drauf zu.
Ähm.
Machen wir das doch jetzt erstmal schnell.
Hier, Docker, Run, Grafana.
Ich glaub, man kann das einfach so ausführen, ohne
irgendwas.
Man kann einfach sagen,
ja, genau.
Nicht Grafana
Enterprise, alter.
Und auch nicht Background.
Vordergrund Port 3000,
jawoll, geb ihm, bam.
Ja.
Achso, Grafana, Grafana
ist das Image, ja.
Yep, Clock.
Findet dein Exporter denn
die existierenden No-
What the fuck?
Mein Exporter ist ein
Sidecar in einem Kubernetes Deployment,
der ist Bestandteil von
einem Node.
Oder von einer
Instanz, die da läuft.
Der kann einfach auf localhost die Sachen abfragen
und dann als Prometheus
Metriken exportieren.
So.
Jetzt heißt es, jetzt habe ich auf localhost
ein Grafana.
Default, Default
Name
Admin, Admin
glaube, gäh?
Nee, Admin Grafana.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Easy.
So, haben wir unser Grafana am Start.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Prometheus.
Prometheus, kann man das nicht einfach mal so
hier installieren über...
Ja.
Brauche ich eine Prometheus-Yaml.
Mal testweise,
um zu gucken, ob das Funs...
Und dann
starten wir mal unser Grafana, um zu gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Also, ähm,
Prometheus-Yaml.
Kann ich mir nicht merken, wie das
Basic-mäßig aussieht. Hier,
da. Basic
Prometheus-Yaml.
Brom-Yaml.
Bam.
Scrape-Intervall
5 Sekunden, external labels.
Bromannet.
Dokumentation ist
überflüssig. Static, config, target.
Wir targeten localhost
port 8080.
Ist das...
Wobei, brauche ich das überhaupt, wenn ich das
hier schon hab? So, und jetzt kann ich sagen,
Prometheus, äh,
config...
Es muss Prometheus-Yaml heißen.
Ah ja.
Und nicht Yammel, sondern Prometheus-Yimmel.
Chatge, wie benennt ihr eure
Yammelfiles? Yammel oder Yimmel?
Ich benenne immer Yammel.
Okay, Prometheus-Exporter
läuft. Äh, nicht
Exporter, Prometheus selber läuft.
Dann schauen wir doch mal. Machen wir mal
das Grafana auf und sagen
jetzt Datasource.
Wisst ihr, eine Sache, die mich bei Grafana
ein bisschen nervt, die ändern auch
ihr GUI alle furzlang.
Jetzt baut ihr gerade, wir bauen einen Prometheus-Exporter
in Go. Connection ist
es jetzt eher. Ne,
Datasource. Datasource.
Add Datasource. Prometheus.
Prometheus.
http://localhost
port 9090
müsste es sein.
Keine
Authentifizierung. Passt alles.
Save and tap...
Ah ne, 3000.
Ne, Moment.
3000 ist Grafana. Auf welchem Port läuft
es? Läuft es jetzt?
Let's see.
9090.
Ne, 9090 läuft es.
Grafana will
ich ja an den... Was hat er für
Schmerzen? Ist er auch da?
Oh, was?
Ey, das brauche ich ja dafür auch
gar nicht.
Was hat er jetzt für...
Achso, Localhost geht ja nicht, weil Grafana
im Container läuft.
Alter, ist ja logisch.
Da muss ich ja meine
IP angeben von dem,
wo Prometheus drauf läuft.
Ah ja, schon besser.
Schon besser.
Okay, alles klar. Home.
Alles klar.
Explore.
Last Block.
Guck mal, er hat es schon erkannt.
Ja.
Mein Counter ist mittlerweile
bei...
Ja, guck, er hat
meinen Kram schon abgepickt.
Okay, nice.
Jetzt können wir nämlich ordentlich testen.
Jetzt können wir es nämlich ordentlich ausprobieren,
wenn ich den Mist hier drinne habe.
Ok.
Moin.
Alles klar. Jetzt können wir ja mal so tun.
Polygon Scan.
Jetzt können wir ja mal so tun, als
hätten wir einen Blockchain-Node laufen.
Ähm...
Latest Blocks. Ja, exakt, der Block.
Das ist das, was mich wahnsinnig interessiert.
So.
Last Block.
Den updaten wir jetzt einfach mal nicht.
Okay, dann bleibt jetzt Static
immer auf dem gleichen Value.
Was ist denn eigentlich ein Value?
Description?
Haben wir?
Warte mal, haben wir?
What?
Channel?
Okay, keine Ahnung. Go.
Das ist mir zu... Ah, Moment, ich habe ja einen Counter.
Ich will ja gar keinen Counter.
Wenn ich einfach irgendwelche Werte
setzen möchte, dann will ich keinen Counter,
sondern, ich glaube, eine...
eine Gauch.
Ne. Eine.
Ah, Moment. Bin ja auch...
bin ja auch ein Noob.
Ist auch hier falsch.
Ich will ja auch...
Gauch.
Was hier...
Opt.
Alles klar. Hat das jetzt reloaded?
Machen wir hier Curl.
Äh...
Curl auf des Matrix.
Ja.
23. Okay, okay.
Das kann man jetzt zwar incrementen, das will ich aber nicht.
Jetzt kann man jetzt aber auch, jetzt kann man den Wert auf jeden Fall
setzen.
Klau, dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich brauche übrigens mal meine Keybindings.
Das nervt mich.
Äh...
VS Coach?
Checkt der das dann?
Ah, nice!
Jetzt habe ich meine Standard-Keybindings,
die ich auswendig kenne.
Zumindest die wichtigsten. Herr Crusher, moin!
Also.
Jetzt heißt das aber auch...
Genauso.
Wie kann ich den... Ich will den Wert einmalig
entsetzen. Last Block.
Add.
Set.
Wahrscheinlich.
Kann man in Prometheus
irgendwie sagen, welche
Unit
diese Metrik hat?
Oder muss man das rein
im Frontend einstellen und wissen?
Also in Grafana kann man ja einstellen,
dieser Wert ist, keine Ahnung,
Unix Timestamp
oder Seconds oder
Megabytes oder sowas.
Kann ja nur zahlen, im Endeffekt.
Weiß aber nicht, ob man Prometheus
quasi schon auch exportieren lassen
kann.
Welche Unit das Ganze ist.
Glaube nicht.
Ich glaubte,
das musst du dann hier in die Hilfe
reinschreiben. So.
Jetzt bekomme ich den letzten Block.
Dann müsste die Unit in Grafana noch so oder so
händisch... Ja, muss so. Es wäre halt cool,
wenn man das tun... Aber wahrscheinlich ist
einfach in den Hilfetext rein.
Laut Convention sollte
der Metrik-Name die Unit am Ende
enthalten. Okay.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch besser, guckt mal,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch besser, wenn ich die Metrik
so nenne, oder? Last Block
ID. Dann weiß man nämlich,
das ist gar keine Einheit, sondern das
ist halt die Unique ID von dem
Block. Was findet ihr besser?
Last Block oder Last Block ID?
Ich glaube, Last Block ID ist besser,
weil dann können wir auch sowas machen
wie Last Block Timestamp
und sowas.
Nehmen wir erstmal Last Block ID.
Moment, wir können auch einfach die Rename-Funktion
verwenden, die aus irgendwelchen
Gründen nicht hiermit aufblockt
in GoLand. Warum nicht?
Refactor, Rename.
ID.
Was? Okay.
Ich dachte, das macht er einfach so.
Okay, das Ding heißt
Last Block
ID.
Dann brauchen wir noch Last
Block
Time?
Last Block
Wie würde man das Ding jetzt nennen?
Also, mal angenommen, ich will jetzt was mit einem
Timestamp. Dann heißt
das Ding, soll ich es Last Block
TS nennen? Oder soll
ich, soll ich, soll ich es,
also, das Ding ist ja, also
ein Timestamp kann ja verschiedene Formate haben.
Gehen wir mal
davon aus, das wäre Unix Time.
Würde ich das dann TS
Unix oder wie, wie ist
es eine gute, wie ist eine gute Benamung dafür?
Wahrscheinlich Last Block TS
und in Hilfe würde ich dann
quasi reinschreiben
Creation Time of
Last Block in
Unix Time oder sowas.
Oh, mein Auge, Alter.
Naming.
A magic name must comply
with, should be a single word
unit.
Must have a single unit.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Timestamp, for a
Timestamp that tracks the time of the latest
process
Timestamp seconds. Okay.
Das sagt aber immer noch
nicht, dass das Unix Time ist.
Aber das finde ich okay.
Würdest
du, Andreas, würdest du da ID hinten
dran hängen, damit das klarer ist,
was das ist?
Das ist, es ist keine Unit,
aber es ergibt schon Sinn, dass
du weißt, dass es keine Unit braucht.
Okay, das finde ich, das ist aber okay.
Also. Und in der Hilfe steht
dann eben das, was Unix Time
Seconds ist. Nicht
Milliseconds, da sind die sich ja immer nicht so
einig.
Seconds since
1970 ist das, glaube ich.
Ja.
Aber das ist okay.
Das finde ich nice. So, Prometheus Labels
und so, das kann man vielleicht später
irgendwas machen. Also.
Die ID bleibt gleich, da muss ich
mir jetzt keine Gedanken machen.
Aber der Timestamp,
der Timestamp ist echt
so ein Ding, das muss ich jetzt
von
PolygonScan abfragen.
Das heißt, wir müssen
jetzt ein HTTP-Request machen
zu PolygonScan.
PolygonScan
API.
Kann man das auch ohne API-Key
verwenden?
Oh no.
Geht das auch ohne API-Key?
Please, lasst mich eure API ohne API-Key verwenden.
Und blendet mich nicht so.
Blendet mich nicht.
Das ist mir zu hell.
Das blickst ja lange für den Sub.
Ich brauche eine API-Key.
Oh, ich brauche eine API-Key.
Wisst ihr was? Wisst ihr was? Wir faken das jetzt einfach.
Wir
greppen uns das da raus.
Weil was mich interessiert ist hier,
dieser Timestamp, der interessiert mich.
Passen wir auf, wir können, wir, wir, wir,
wir web-scrapen das jetzt.
Jawoll, perfekt.
Und wie heißt das hier?
Timestamp?
Timestamp.
What the f...
Hier!
Ah, guck mal!
Das steht ja da sogar direkt in Unix-Time
drinne.
Okay, also, show UTC local date.
Ich greppe,
ich greppe nach data-timestamp.
curl-s
Ja?
Wobei, Moment, Moment, ich greppe, ich greppe da gar nichts.
Ich muss das ja in Go machen.
Ich muss dann quasi in Go sowas
wie greppen.
Okay, ich greppe nach
Timestamp. Wir machen das mal ganz kurz
in Bash.
Dann cutten wir das Ganze
am Gleichheitszeichen. Nehmen wir das dritte Feld.
Ne!
Öh!
Ne, wir
splitten nicht am
Gleichheitszeichen, wir splitten an
Wir splitten
an datran.
Excellent!
Excellent, excellent!
So, und das ist Unix-Time.
Das sieht, das sieht, das sieht
nach Unix-Time-Seconds aus, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, das ist
eindeutig Unix-Time-Seconds.
Alles klar, okay.
Es ist, es ist High-IQ, Andreas.
Das mit, äh, Look, Look
Heads und Dings und, äh,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie dieses Konstrukt
korrekt jetzt heißt.
Aber allein schon, wenn man in Grepp
Perlregex einschalten muss,
dann weiß man, irgendwas ist falsch.
Sobald man Perlregex braucht in
Grepp, ist, ist irgendwie
sus. Ich bleib,
ich bleib bei meinem. Ich finde, das ist besser lesbar.
Aber davon abgesehen, wir können das in Go eh
nicht machen, weil in Go können wir nicht greppen und
und cutten. Wie macht man ein Web-Request
in Go? Jetzt, jetzt
geht's los, Leute. Ich, ich komme
halt hier diesen ganzen Kreppel mal aus, weil ich nicht
weiß aus dem Kopf, wie man ein Web-Request in
Go macht.
http get in go
Jawoll.
nethttp
Da macht man einfach http
.get
its
itsy
So. Und jetzt so was
response. Ah, Moment,
jetzt muss ich ja Error-Handling machen.
Naja, da schlägt ja eh nix fehl.
Wird, wird nicht, wird kein Error gehandelt.
Was ist das hier? Error-Handling.
Keck.
Okay, Error.
Ja, man sollte
Web-Request sollte man schon, schon
erroren.
Und wie, wie war das jetzt nochmal in Go?
Warum kann das hier die,
warum kann die IDE
mir kein, kein Error-Handling generieren?
Muss man,
wie war das? If,
if r,
ge?
Und dann kannst du sagen,
ja, das soll dann gar nicht
crashen. Ähm,
weiß ich noch nicht
genau, was dann passiert.
So, und in der
Response, Moment, das war doch in
Go so, du kannst die Response nicht einfach
lesen. Du musst doch irgendwie sowas machen.
I O read all
oder irgendwie sowas, ge?
War das nicht so? Ne.
Body?
Ja, so war das, genau.
Fmt. Brindeln?
Nicht Brindeln. Brindeln?
Okay.
Äh, hat das jetzt
funktioniert?
Moin Patrick. Run. Nein, will nicht. Weil, warum?
Was ist? Sonntags.
Unexpected new line in argument list.
Possible missing, ach so.
Ah, das
fuckt mich halt immer echt ab an Go,
das Zeug hier. Ob, es ist gar nicht
das Problem. Was?
Äh.
Ah.
Ich hab die Klammer nicht zugemacht.
Was ist der
Vorteil von Go ge...
NO GOD!
Ach, ich muss erst noch sagen, dass es ein
String ist, ge? Muss man
nicht noch irgendwie sagen, String oder so?
Ne, Moment, das war
Python-Kram.
Äh.
Moment. Stack, Stack
Overflow, Stack Overflow.
Go http
response s
String, da gibt's doch bestimmt was kürzeres, wie
dass ich da... Ja, genau.
Tatsächlich, man muss es ernsthaft
so machen. Da gibt es nix
kürzeres als das.
Ja, Go ist manchmal schon ein bisschen weird,
weird champ.
Auf der anderen Seite, eines der Sachen
von Go ist ja...
Äh, ne.
Warum?
Moment, wie jetzt?
Hä, hab ich doch gemacht. Ach so,
das kann auch fehlschlagen.
Ach, das kann auch
fehlschlagen, okay.
Okay, ist ja gut, Go.
Aber das ist mir egal, ob das fehlschlägen
kann. Es wird jetzt
einfach...
So, und jetzt aber, ha?
Ne, Moment. Moment, das ist ja kein String. Das ist, äh,
wie nennt das hier? B!
Guck, der weiß auch nicht, wie der's nennen soll, weil er's einfach
B nennt.
Äh, B.
Bester.
So, und jetzt? String.
So, ne? So, alles klar.
So.
Jetzt muss...
gekrappt werden in Go.
Okay.
Ähm...
Regex, ja. Aber gibt es nicht
sowas wie, ich lupe
all lines?
Ich... Oh, ne, Regex.
Okay, Regex, Regex, Regex.
Go, Regex.
Äh, what?
Äh...
Was will der von mir?
Okay.
Regex, Regex, Regex, Regex.
Okay, wir brauchen...
Ich muss mir, ich muss mir nen Regex ausdenken, der das Ganze jetzt matcht.
Okay?
Ja, dann nehmen wir doch einfach den...
Da hat der Andreas nicht vorher HighIQRegex gepostet?
Der Karlsson, danke schön für den Sub.
Geht's...
Geht das nicht irgendwie ein bisschen einfacher?
Ne, das ist, das ist nur für grepp, weil das, weil das
O das sonst nicht matcht, gell?
Das brauchen wir gar nicht
so kompliziert zu machen.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt einfach suchen.
Kennst du Regex 1 und...
Ja, das kenn ich, das kenn ich.
Ich kenn auch Regex Lab und solche.
Da können wir das machen, aber wir probieren das jetzt mal so.
Also Start, Start ist mir eigentlich...
Warum sind das Backticks, Leute?
Warum sind das
Backticks und keine Quotes?
Was sind denn...
Kann man jetzt für Strings
in Go auch sowas hier machen, neuerdings?
Oder wie? Ne, kann man nicht.
Doch kann man.
Was, was ist das?
Was ist...
Kann man da jetzt Variablen einsetzen oder irgendwas?
Oder was ist... Hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Backticks für Strings in Go.
Okay, wir suchen nach
Data
Timestamp.
Sind das vielleicht Regex Strings? Ich glaube nicht, dass die dafür
einen eigenen Typ haben.
Gut, das ist ein String. Ne, das ist ein ganz normaler String.
Das könnte man auch...
Das ist vielleicht ein String, der irgendwie
keine...
Ne, dann weiß ich nicht.
Use raw Strings to avoid having to
quote the backslashes. Aha!
Okay.
Also...
Ähm...
Wie kriegen wir...
Wie kriegen wir das denn jetzt raus?
TS, Regex, find.
Ah, guck mal, da kann man direkt
den, den, den... Kann man das so machen?
Ne.
Aber man kann hier... Body.
Aha, okay.
Find.
Was kommt da jetzt... Was kommt da jetzt raus?
Null. Okay.
Das hat er nicht gefunden.
Aber warum nicht?
Timestamp kommt da drin vor.
Muss ich... Muss ich Punkt... Muss ich sagen Punkt Sternchen?
Timestamp?
Äh...
Hä?
Ähm... Warum matcht
das nicht?
Okay, da muss ein D drinne vorkommen.
Ah, D kommt drinne vor. Okay.
Und Data?
Data kommt drinne... Ach, wegen dem...
Wegen dem Minus vielleicht, oder?
Kommt da drin Timestamp vor?
Vor... What?
Was ist das für Magic?
Okay.
Vielleicht... Find all?
Okay, jetzt bin...
Jetzt bin ich zu pipiga, das zu checken, wie das
funktioniert.
Das Grab geht noch, habe ich eben ausgeführt.
Guck.
Äh...
Was fand's noch?
What the f...
Wie... Wie...
Wie...
Müsste das nicht erst ein String sein?
Hatte ich ja eben auch schon ausprobiert.
Match... Match String.
Body. Ist jetzt... Ist jetzt... Ist jetzt ja einer.
Guck, wenn ich das hier ausgebe...
Ups.
Wenn ich das hier ausgebe...
Brindeln...
Dann kommt die Webseite dabei raus.
Und in der Webseite ist Grab...
Timestamp.
Äh...
Was?
Wie jetzt?
Das ist doch genau das gleiche, was ich hier gette.
Warum ist hier... Warum ist hier
Timestamp drinne?
Und hier ist nicht Timestamp drinne.
Detekten die irgendwie, dass das ein Go?
Äh... Abfrage ist?
Und deswegen... Deswegen darf ich nicht?
Oder... Oder was ist das?
Die Seite sieht auch ganz anders aus.
Was ist das für eine Seite?
Das... Ist das irgendein
DDoS-Schutz, oder?
Challenge! Oh nein!
Das...
Aber...
Mit Curl funktioniert es ohne Probleme!
Okay, was...
Was für... Was für
Header setzt Curl denn da?
Äh...
User-Agent. Wo ist denn der User-Agent?
Seht ihr den gerade?
HTTP2!
Wow! Jetzt... Jetzt wollen sie es aber
wissen, oder?
Äh... User-Agent.
Hier. Curl.
Machen wir mal.
Wir setzen User-Agent.
Ähm... Wie macht man das denn
jetzt?
Wie... Wie setzt man da jetzt?
Sagt man jetzt Send, oder so?
Wie setzt... Wie setzt man da einen Header?
Gibt es da eine Option für Header?
Ne, das wäre auch zu einfach, wenn man
da Header-Option setzen könnte.
Äh... Go HTTP
Get Header.
How to set headers?
Äh... What?
Okay, das kann nicht sein.
New Request.
Ach. Okay.
Aha.
Alles klar. Alles klar.
Okay.
Oh.
Ähm...
Ja. Okay. Gehen wir.
Zack. Kommt das hier weg?
Okay. Request. Error wird
nicht... Geh fort, Alter. Error-Handling.
Keck. Wait.
New Request. Get...
So. Wie war das jetzt hier?
Request Header Add.
Und da wollen wir jetzt...
User Agent.
Muss man natürlich so schreiben,
weil das einfach zu... zu einfach
wäre sonst. So. Und
jetzt kann ich wahrscheinlich sagen Request
Send.
Request Send. Ne. Request Get.
Get... Get Body.
Wo findest du das jetzt?
Du.
Okay, das ist ja super
eklig, Mann.
Client. Du? Wer hat
sich die Abi dann ausgedacht, Mann?
Da... Da... Da...
Leck ich aber gern Critical Information,
dass ich bisher nicht wusste, wie das in Go funktioniert.
So.
Und jetzt... Jetzt sag ich wahrscheinlich
Response und wieder Error.
Da gibt's doch bestimmt schon tausende
Api...
HTTP Client Wrapper für Go,
dass das nicht so eklig ist.
So. Und jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob's jetzt funktioniert.
Aha. Jetzt funzt's.
Okay. Easy. Easy.
User Agent Curl.
This is the way.
Das brauchen wir.
So. Und jetzt Compile
Match String.
True.
True lul w.
Find.
String.
Timestamp.
Okay. Funzt. Funzt. Alles klar. Gut.
Hat funktioniert.
Hat... Hat funktioniert.
Okay. Timestamp. So. Und jetzt müssen wir extra
extrahieren. Jetzt müssen wir sowas wie Matching Group
machen.
Jetzt müssen wir sowas wie Matching Group machen.
Okay. Timestamp gleich.
Wie sah das nochmal aus?
Data
Timestamp.
Okay. Timestamp gleich.
Also Timestamp gleich. Mal gucken, ob
das das kann.
Und dann Non-Creedy Match.
Okay.
Passt.
Ach nee. Moment. Es muss Anführungszeichen
sein. Nein.
So. Und jetzt ist die Frage.
Matching Groups?
Question mark.
Wie kann ich da jetzt drauf
zugreifen?
Group. Match.
Find all String
Submatch.
Oh.
Nee.
String int.
What?
Okay. Go regex match
group.
How to get capturing group. Jawoll.
Wie geht das?
Cross reference capture name
three sub
Was? Was?
Was wollt ihr von mir?
Ich check's nicht.
Kannst du doch nicht einfach
Substring machen?
Ja. Wahrscheinlich könnte ich mir das
rausholen und dann
splitten. Ich könnte splitten.
Aber ich mein.
Aber es muss doch
irgendwie Matching
Groups geben in Go.
What?
Sub exp names?
Okay.
Also was?
Find
String
Submatch.
Okay.
Ich kann bestimmt noch sagen find
Submatch, oder?
Find String
Submatch.
Das ist richtig.
Find String
Ah ja.
Okay. Und da kann ich jetzt quasi
sagen array index 1
wahrscheinlich.
Oh.
Eats. Eats. Eats. Eats.
Eats. Eats. Eats. Eats. Eats.
Okay.
Timestamp gleich das da.
fmt brindeln
Timestamp.
Jetzt können wir übrigens wieder
R benutzen.
Ja. Nice. Okay.
Das müssen wir jetzt alle paar Sekunden machen.
Wobei der
Timestamp ändert sich ja nicht.
Naja. Wir tun jetzt mal als ändert sich aber
der last block. Okay.
Sind wir mal nicht so.
Also. Ich will zwei Sachen damit machen.
Anmetrigen.
Das kann ich mir mal
copy, copy, pasten.
Den Client können wir uns
wahrscheinlich hier oben speichern.
Den request
den müssen wir aber
ändern.
Jedes mal wenn sich.
Na gut. Der Block ändert sich jetzt gerade nicht.
Wir faken das mal.
Okay. Also. Wir haben einmal
last block id.
Und dann haben wir
last block time.
Last block time lese ich jetzt gerade hier da drüber
aus.
So.
Dann kommentieren wir den ganzen Schmodder mal wieder ein.
Also das ist die
id. Die bleibt immer
fest. Das ist okay so.
In der Function
alle. Sag mal.
Wir wollen uns ja mal nicht blocken lassen. Okay.
Alle fünf Sekunden.
Der Rest passt.
Fragen wir das hier ab.
Da kann man doch bestimmt
eine eigene Function hier machen.
Get block.
Ach ja. Wie ist denn die go naming
convention. Ist es get block
ts oder ist es
get block.
Wahrscheinlich ist es so.
Get block
ts.
Dann machen wir jetzt irgendwie float
64 block id.
Ne Moment.
Ha. Das ist ja go.
Das ist so rum.
Kann man.
Moment. Kann man sowas machen wie const client.
Ne. Natürlich nicht. Wär zu einfach.
War. Client.
So. Ja.
Okay. Das funzt.
Dann schmeißen wir das weg.
Jetzt hier
request
und dann return
timestamp.
Ach ja. Man muss ja
angeben, dass der was return. Und zwar soll der
kann er. Warum kann der das nicht automatisch
für mich aus. Ach doch. Geht doch.
Genau. So. Jetzt kriege ich hier den
string zurück. Wenn ich dem den block
übergebe. Der block
ist das hier. Das hardcoden wir jetzt mal.
Also alle paar. Alle paar Sekunden.
Also die id.
müssen wir nicht incrementen. Das macht keinen Sinn.
Also wir sagen jetzt alle
5 Sekunden.
get block
ts. So. Dann übergeben wir die
block id.
Und dann setzen wir
last block time
set
auf
Ja. String ist
eigentlich doof. Ne. Ich hätte das gleich
Ich sollte da gleich einen float zurück
geben und gar kein
string. Macht ja. Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Kann man. Wie passt
man in go ein string
als float. So wahrscheinlich
nicht. Ist das
aot. Ne. Wie heißt dieser
Krempel.
Go string to float
Oder ist es
float 64 und dann irgendwas mit
A
toy war das. Genau.
A toy. Das kann sein, dass ich das meine.
Ne.
Strikonf. What?
Between float
and string.
Strikonf pass float.
Ok. Strikonf. Warum
ist das nicht
irgendein. Irgendwas
in der float 64 Klasse.
Oder Klasse stimmt ja nicht. Typ.
Strikonf
float
pass
float. Was?
Bit size int?
Ah.
Oh das ist ja eklig. Warum heißt es nicht
pass float 32 und pass
float 64?
Ok. Pass float
string timestamp
Das checkt der jetzt oder wie?
Bin ja mal gespannt.
Ok. Ja dann return auch noch
nen error. So what? Ok.
Kann ja immer alles erroren im Zweifelsfall.
Wenn man das mal nicht findet.
Alles gut. Go.
Besser.
Erst mal alles diskan.
Ok.
Jetzt funzt es oder?
Ja guck mal. Ergibt es aus.
Untersetzt es hoffentlich.
Oder auch nicht.
Also untersetzt es. Ok. Wenn ich jetzt
nen curl da drauf mache.
Dann sollte ich das
als von meinem exporter
bekommen.
Das ist
vermutlich das richtige.
Go ist ein bisschen
haarig. Oder ein bisschen
hakelig in manchen Fällen.
Das gute an Go ist.
Was man
eigentlich schon irgendwie zu schätzen wissen muss.
Das Go relativ
wenig Magic macht.
In Go musst du jeden Furz
explizit hinschreiben. Zum größten Teil
zumindest. Die haben sich ja auch
jahrelang geweigert sowas wie
Array Map oder
sowas anzubieten. Ich glaube das haben die immer noch nicht.
Oder? Wisst ihr was die Go Standard
Antwort ist? Stellt euch mal vor ihr habt nen Array.
Ja. So.
So und ihr wollt es jetzt filtern.
Filter nach. Wir tun jetzt einfach mal
so als müsst ihr. Filter
alle Elemente wo x größer
als 4 ist. Das geht
ja in Go so nicht.
Wisst ihr was Go sagt?
Go sagt mach ne Vorschleife mit nem if drinne.
Das ist mir dann doch
ein bisschen zu viel des guten.
Wie soll man sagen. Äh.
Raw. Raw. Raw bleiben.
Ja. Das liegt aber
nicht wirklich an Go sondern das liegt
an Rust. Wenn du C Sharp
mit Rust
verglichen hättest
hättest du das gleiche gehabt.
Oder wenn du JavaScript mit Rust verglichen hättest
hättest du das gleiche
gehabt. Ich behaupte sogar in den Sprachen
wärst du gar noch schneller gewesen als in Go.
Aber bei Go geht's schon
in Ordnung. Der große Vorteil
von Go übrigens jetzt mal jetzt nicht auf
die Sprache selbst bezwungen. Der große
Vorteil was in Go zu programmieren sind
self-contained binaries. Go
eignet sich super um die Anwendung
simpel zu vercontainerisieren.
Du kriegst ein Binary raus
das kopierst du in deinen Container und es ist fertig.
Es geht einfach.
Wisst ihr was? Ich hab's schon lange nicht mehr in Dark gesehen.
Wenn du es zuerst in Rust gemacht hast
hattest du vielleicht auch ein bisschen
schneller das in Go
programmiert.
Surrendered. Warum? Es macht Bock. Best game ever.
Also wir
haben jetzt den Timestamp gesetzt.
Dann lasst uns grad mal ins Grafana gucken.
Wobei noch
sehen wir in unserem Grafana ja gar nix.
Wir müssen jetzt noch ne. Wir brauchen noch ne
Metric Leute. Das ist
wir haben jetzt Last Block
ID, Last Block
Timestamp
und was wir jetzt noch brauchen ist
Last Block
Wie nennt man das?
Ich will jetzt ausrechnen
wie viel Zeit vergangen ist.
Duration?
Age nennen wir das.
Last Block Age.
Ich will gucken wie alt der Block ist.
Also relativ zur aktuellen Zeit.
Oh das heißt wir müssen
Date Time Calculations in Go machen?
Das wird
Painschamp. Ich ahne es jetzt schon.
So das ist Last Block
Darf man das?
Age Seconds
Ist das die korrekte Go
Schreibweise?
Lasst uns von Grafana ausrechnen.
Das würde funktionieren
tatsächlich.
Das würde in dem Fall funktionieren
weil du in Prometheus
also Grafana rechnet das ja nicht aus
weil du in Prometheus glaube ich
eine Time
different oder sowas Function hast.
Ja das
könntest du machen.
Aber wir machen es jetzt trotzdem mal
weil ich wissen will wie es funktioniert.
Klar ich spiele
es bis nächste Season.
Ich will mal. Ok da machen wir es.
Doch wir machen das jetzt mal.
Weil ich wissen will ob es funktioniert.
Wir nennen das mal Last Age Seconds.
Ist auch wurscht.
Und jetzt
setzen wir das. Ich möchte jetzt mal
Date Time Magic
Last Block Age
Set. Wir schreiben jetzt mal 1 rein
weil
weil Go sonst nervt.
Also wie
würden wir das ausrechnen?
Ich habe jetzt
Timestamp
in Unix Time.
Wie kriege ich
in Go
Go lang in Unix Time.
Wie kann ich in
Go ein
Date Time Objekt
erzeugen aus einem Unix
Timestamp.
Und wie kann ich in Go überhaupt Sachen
voneinander abziehen. Also ich will
sowas wie Time Now haben. Sowas gibts
doch oder? Im Prinzip will
ich sowas hier machen.
Ja
Age oder Duration
oder wie auch immer. Im Prinzip
will ich sowas machen.
Es gibt Time Unix. Ja wirklich?
Ach
Also im Prinzip will ich
Time Unix
und keine Nanoseconds.
Das funktioniert
natürlich nicht. Warum?
Warum nicht?
Warum Go? Warum kann ich das nicht
voneinander abziehen?
Warum funktioniert das nicht? Was hat er denn für
Schmerzen?
Invalid Operation.
Ach es ist kein Minus Operator.
Muss von Sub machen.
Ok TS geht nicht. Warum?
Cannot use TS
Type Float. 64S Type
in
64. Ok. Also müssen
wir das jetzt wahrscheinlich
casten. Was ist denn nur mit casten
los?
So.
Wir sind ja in Go. Wir sollten das so machen.
Das kann natürlich wieder wahrscheinlich
fehlschlagen. Deswegen ignorieren wir einfach
den Error. Ne. Der meckert
dass die Variablen nicht.
Ok. Last Block Age
Set.
Moment. Duration. Das ist jetzt ein Duration
Objekt. Wie kriege ich ein
Duration Objekt in Seconds?
Aha. Hier. Float 64.
Excellent.
By the way. Warum hat er nicht erkannt
dass er reloaden soll?
Er ist gecrashed.
Nice.
Bam.
Go run.
Curl.
Warum exportiert
er nur Block ID?
Ah. Weil ich Noob bin.
Weil ich nur Block ID exportiere. Ich muss eigentlich noch
Last Block
Time und Last Block Age.
Aha.
Ähm. Ja.
Das. Ja.
Das funzt Leute.
Wenn er
aktualisiert nur alle 5 Sekunden.
Ja. Guck mal.
Ja. Nice. Nice. Nice.
Funzt.
Ähm. Jetzt gucken wir mal in unser Grafana
rein. Ob er das da auch checkt.
Ja.
Last Block
Age Seconds.
Ja.
Nice.
Ja. Das ist ja cool.
Gib mir schon Time
Since.
Ok. Das ist natürlich besser.
Also quasi Time.
Ah.
Ja. Da haben sie sich was gedacht.
Bei Go.
Bei den Go Leuten.
Ok. Das gefällt mir aber ganz gut.
Ja. Das funzt hier tatsächlich.
Guck mal.
Last Block Age Seconds, Instance und so
ist dabei.
Ja. Cool.
Alles ist besser als
Daytime in JavaScript.
Haben die nicht vor ner ganzen Weile
angekündigt. JavaScript bekommt eine neue
Daytime API.
Gibt es die mittlerweile schon?
Temporal oder so.
Genau. Can I Use?
Gucken wir mal.
Temporal. Heißt das so?
Nein. Normalerweise
geht das schneller. Also wenn das Sachen
sind wo die Hersteller scharf drauf sind
implementieren die das in Browsern
schon bevor das überhaupt
standardisiert ist.
Wobei es ist glaube ich noch nicht standardisiert.
Aber. Und das
muss man den JavaScript Leuten echt
wirklich zugute halten.
Wenn die was machen hat das Hand und Fuß
nicht wie C++
das C++ Gremium. Wo du das
Gefühl hast jeder der nur genug
Einfluss in diesem Gremium hat kann da irgendwas
irgendwas quasi
wie soll man sagen
einbringen und das wird dann genommen und die
C++ Standard Library funktioniert alles
anders. Also das muss man echt sagen
das JavaScript Gremium macht meiner Meinung
nach da echt gute Arbeit.
Wenn halt auch langsam.
Hatte ich eben Can I Use offen?
Wo hatte ich denn Can I Use offen Karl?
Hier.
Safari Technology Preview
Und was sagt
Wie sieht es denn mit Firefox aus?
Moment.
Wollen die mir ernsthaft sagen
Safari hat was schneller
als Chrome
und Firefox?
Ernsthaft?
Ja okay Technology Preview
Das glaube ich erst wenn ich es sehe
Tatsächlich
Alter
Safari hat mal was zuerst
Dass ich das
noch erleben darf
Safari ist eigentlich der neue Internet Explorer
Was Features
angeht. Ja aber natürlich nur Desktop Safari
Ja IOS Safari selbstverständlich nicht
Ludl
Ich muss sagen
Die Go Library ist vielleicht
auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen
ekelig aber auf den zweiten Blick jetzt muss ich sagen
ist es relativ straight forward zu benutzen
alles
Also der korrekte Weg das zu machen
wäre tatsächlich nicht mit Age
sondern wir sagen
Last Block Timestamp Seconds
Jetzt
bin ich aber aufgeschmissen weil ich nicht
weiß wie man das in PromQL gescheit macht
Also hier Last Block Seconds
Das ist 1,71
Billions
Das ist Unix Time Seconds
Das sind Sekunden
seit 1.1.1970
Und warum ist das so?
Weil sich das mal irgendjemand ausgedacht hat
dass es ein gutes Zeitformat ist
Sekunden seit
1.1.1970
Manche machen auch
Millisekunden seit 1.1.1970
Und es sind
1,71
Billionen
Sekunden vergangen seit
1.1.1970
Wird das dann negativ wenn es
vor dem 1.1. ist?
Also theoretisch schon
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das überhaupt
definiert ist
Also unter Linux oder generell Unix
es gibt keine Zeit vor dem 1.1.1970
Ja du könntest das schon negativ darstellen
aber ich glaube das ist
nicht etabliert
Die Zeitrechnung beginnt
am 1.1.1970
In Unix Time
Das ist das
Das ist die Stunde 0 sozusagen
Also mal unsere PromQL
5 Hats
Brauchen wir jetzt mal hier
So
Wir stellen das jetzt mal um
Wie
Time Function
Oh guck mal der Andreas weiß das bestimmt
Der hat sowas schon gemacht
Der wirkte vorher sehr 5 Hats was das angeht
Wie würde ich jetzt mit PromQL
Das ausrechnen
Oder hast du nicht schon
gar was geschrieben vorhin
Mal gucken
Ich hab vorhin schon irgendwas geschrieben
PromQL und TimeNow
Ne
Also die Prometheus Metriken sind
defined als
Float 6040
Die könnten theoretisch negativ sein
Range Functions
Time Functions
Day of Month
Ne das ergibt ja gar keinen Sinn
Es ist der
20.
Also
Also was
Time
Minus Timestamp
Und der checkt auch
Unix Time Seconds will der also schon haben
Tatsächlich
Cool
Guck mal wie er das aus dem Kopf weiß
Da muss man wirklich ernsthaft mal sagen
Also der Chat hier ist schon
Most High IQ
Stellts auf ganz Twitch
Wo hast du sonst noch Leute auf Twitch
Die sowas wissen
Bei Amorant
Im
Poolstream bestimmt nicht
Oh hier siehst du gar nicht
Die einzelnen Steps
Ja
Um jetzt mal zu vergleichen
Wie akkurat das ganze hier ist
Machen wir Add Query
Und da trage ich mal mein Age in Seconds ein
Run
Ja
Ist schon ziemlich ähnlich oder
Die blaue
Die grüne und die gelben Bars
Ist schon ziemlich ähnlich
Also das
Ich geb dir recht
Das ist die deutlich schönere Variante hier
Habt ihr noch irgendeine Idee
Was für Metriken sinnvoll wären
In dem Kontext
Ich hab ja hier schon öfters mal Sachen gefragt
Und die Leute hatten richtig nice Ideen
Also
Die eigentliche
Das sind die drei Metriken die uns erstmal interessieren
Die letzte Block ID
Und das Age
Wie gesagt
Nicht machen
Können wir uns selbst ausrechnen
Kannst du kurz für einen Loop erklären was du machst
Ja
Ich programmier einen eigenen Prometheus Exporter
Jetzt weißt du Bescheid oder
Aber ich kanns dir auch genauer erklären
Prometheus ist eine Monitoring Software
Wo du Infos abfragen kannst
Von bestimmten Endpunkten
Kannst du zum Beispiel abfragen
Was ist das
Du kannst zum Beispiel über Prometheus abfragen
Wie voll ist die Festplatte auf meinem Server
So und dann
Sammelst du das ein
Und dann kannst du hier in so einem
Graphing Tool wie Grafana
Die Infos dann auswählen
Da kannst du ja so einen Graph machen
Hier Festplatten Füllstand über den letzten Monat
Natürlich kann Prometheus nicht nur so Standardmetriken sammeln
Sondern auch eigene Metriken
Und wir brauchen dafür
Einen Note Exporter
Einen Prometheus Exporter
Der diese Metriken exportiert
Und ich will für eine Blockchain Anwendung
Exportieren
Was die letzte Block ID ist
Und
Was die Block ID für einen Timestamp hat
Damit man das dann
Hier grafisch darstellen kann
Und im Zweifelsfall auch direkt auf den ersten Blick sieht
Das Ding hängt
Weil sich die letzte Block ID
Quasi nicht ändert
Ja
Du hast Recht vielleicht soll ich das umbenennen
Ja es ist der letzte Block gemeint
Der Node quasi gesehen hat
Oder der letzte
Node den der gesynct hat
Im Endeffekt
Alert müssen wir mal gucken
Alert können wir aber easy machen wenn die Metrik da ist
Ja vielleicht sollte ich das dann nämlich nicht
Last wobei doch ich nenne es
Last Block ID
Man könnte es auch Node Last Block ID nennen
Was sind sinnvolle Labels
Bei
Weil ich meine das könnte auch
Mehrfach im gleichen Kubernetes Cluster laufen
Wobei du kriegst ja
Extra Labels schon dran
Für die Instance und sowas
Also ich glaube wir brauchen
Ehrlich gesagt gar keine Labels
Doch Labels
Doch Blockchain
Welche das ist
Weil das siehst du anhand der
Werte ja nicht
Da muss Blockchain Polygon zum Beispiel rein
In dem Fall
Weil das Ding könnte ja auch
Was weiß ich Bitcoin
Macht er nicht aber könnte ja auch
Oder
Könnte auch
Machen
Und wenn da nicht Polygon dran steht ist natürlich
Blöd da weißt du ja nicht was es ist
Ja da sollte schon Labels Blockchain
Polygon dran stehen ja das ist sinnvoll
Excellent
Ist das
Und wisst ihr was noch nicer ist
Diese
Die Labels die könnte man
Sogar über eine
Über eine Environment Variable
Setzen lassen
Und dann könnte das nämlich
In deinem Kubernetes Deployment
Direkt mit
Mit einer Config Map
Konfigurieren was das jetzt eigentlich ist
Wie macht man
Wie macht man eine Environment Variable in Go
OS
Ich will nicht Set Env
Ich will
Was
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst oder
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst
Ach ne geht doch
OS Get Env
Kann man
Default Value übergeben
Default Value
Ja nenn das irgendwie
For Go Rand
Ja
Das kann
Das kann es jetzt auch fehlschlagen
Ich nenn es einfach nur Name
Moment OS Get Env kann nicht
Fehlschlagen was ist denn wenn es das nicht gibt
Ist es dann einfach leer oder was
Also gerade das hätte ich jetzt eigentlich
Gedacht das es fehlschlagen kann weil es ja
Nicht angelegt sein muss
Es ist einfach
Das ist aber auch nicht konsequent oder
Warum gibt es sowas nicht denn
Jeder Furz gibt in Go einen Error
Aber eine nicht existierte Environment Variable
Gibt empty String
Das heißt ich muss jetzt quasi checken
Ja wobei eigentlich
Ist der Name ist eigentlich
Required
Kannst du nur schlucken
Eigentlich ist Required
Kann man
Okay ich gehe davon aus
Das ich sowas machen muss oder
Gibt es auch
Sowas wie
Not White Space in Go
Also wenn das
Gleich dem ist dann sagen wir hier
Log Fatal
So wie hier unten
Geiler Name
Für eine Funktion
Log Fatal
Keck
0 W größer
Keck W das ist die beste Fehlermeldung dafür
Achso und dann
Error Status
Ja
Nein
Das mache ich nicht
Aber da sieht man schön die Go Philosophie
Jeden Furz explizit hinschreiben
Was
Look Up Enf
What
OS Look Up Enf
Da gibt es den
Bool zurück
Man warum nicht einfach einen Error
Man kann das auch
Look Up Enf
Äh und jetzt
Ne
Hier
Wir können es doch Error nennen ist doch egal
Aber jetzt müssen wir nicht ungleich nennen
Muss
Muss man macht man so
Macht man das so
Oder kann man das irgendwie gleich
Inline machen
If not okay
Dann Fatal Bam
Crash
Das finde ich jetzt wiederum ganz hübsch ehrlich gesagt
Aber das ist gut
Da kann man das ganze direkt über eine
Config Map
Einstellen
Und dann exportiert er das auch immer mit dem
Weil wie gesagt es kann durchaus ja auch sein
Dass das eine ganz andere Blockchain
Technology ist
Okay nice
Da haben wir doch heute wieder was
Gelernt
Der High IQ Reward geht an den
Andreas der sich gut auskennt mit Prom QL
Und
Was war das erste nochmal
Ich hab schon wieder verdrängt
Was war das
Was war das erste schlaue was er geschrieben hat
Äh Prom QL
Such jetzt einfach
Ah Regex
Grab
Grab Pearl Regex
Ja
Probier mal if
Was if name
Okay
Was
What
Name is not
Was
Was ist das
Okay Chatge
Was ist hübscher oder was
Würdet ihr okay
Würdet ihr es lieber mit einem if schreiben oder so
Ist der Name
Da nur in dem Block
Nö glaub ich net
Doch ist nur
Alter das ist ja mal was
So
Ich bin das super
Hässlich ehrlich gesagt
Weil das Ding ist ich will ja crashen
Wenn es nicht geht jetzt kann man sowas machen
Ja kann man
Jetzt kann ich hier crashen
Du schreibst auch Klammern in eigene Zeile
Ja weil das ist das richtige
Aber jetzt merkt er dann das es name nicht gibt
Ja gut ist nicht schlimm
Name würde ich ja hier unten benutzen
Ja die würde ich dann quasi hier einsetzen
Äh
Chatge
Wir machen das nicht so
Weil wie soll ich jetzt auf name zugreifen
Was war
Nö
Mario danke schon für den sub
Nö nö das ist das Funst so nett
Was davor
Nö
Wie jetzt
Nö nö nö
Nö
Äh sicher
Nö Leute das
Ist
Das ist ja
Das ist ja sowas von wir
Das machen wir nicht so
Ok ich muss gleich machen
Aber jetzt geht es mit dem ok nicht
Nö nö
Das machen wir nicht
Wir machen das weg
Und sagen if not ok
Das ist die bessere Variante Chat
So wie wir es ursprünglich hatten ok
So
Jetzt findet er das nicht
Jetzt sag ich export blockchain name gleich
Polygon
Run
Kunst
Und jetzt steht auch Polygon drin
Sehr nice
Und in unserem Grafana auch jetzt
Ups
Ja
Er hat es noch nicht
Er hat es noch nicht gecrawled glaube ich
Warum kein Kibana
Warum kein Telegraf
Ich hab das ja nur hier eingetragen
Ich hab das ja nur eingetragen bei
Block ID
Last Block ID
Guck jetzt steht blockchain name dran
Sehr cool
Das finde ich nice
Das kann man mehr oder weniger schon so morgen verwenden
Naja also vielleicht nicht ganz
Ich sollte dort vielleicht nicht als
Meldung lulwe kekwe und help kekel
Reinschreiben
Aber so von der Idee her
Finde ich das gut
Achja und das wird bei uns dann auch nicht so
Laufen
Also ich werde auch keine Abfrage machen
Gegen Polygon Scan
Sondern Abfrage gegen die interne API
Von der Node Software
Wisst ihr was mich verwirrt
Hier
Woher weiß der
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen
Achso weil es könnte ja ein Error sein
Woher weiß der denn
Dass das ein int
Woher weiß der
Dass es ein float64 ist
Weil
Ach Moment
Es ist immer ein float64
Aber wenn ich hier 32 angebe
Dann ist es auch ein float64
Jetzt verstehe ich den Sinn
Der Bitsize ehrlich gesagt nicht
Ja
Das wirkt ein bisschen hakelig
Ja das verstehe ich
Warum gibt es kein
Pass float 32 und Pass float 64
Warum gibt es so ein komisches
Pass float was immer
Ein 64
Aber auch ein 32 oder ein
15 oder so sein kann
Verstehe ich nicht
Aber gut
Immerhin funktioniert das ziemlich
Ziemlich gut
Jetzt können wir diesen Kram hier gerade mal aufräumen
Immerhin funktioniert das alles ziemlich gut
Das gefällt mir
Also ich würde sagen
Ich werde das morgen noch ein bisschen umbauen
Da brauche ich noch ein Image drum herum
Warum ist das vom Sprintende immer so stressig
Weil ihr nicht
Diagonal skaliert habt
Mit dem entsprechenden Hyperscaler
Ja
Zu wenige
Mikrosprints zwischendurch
Und ihr habt
Sicher nichts
Wo bloß best practices befolgt
Ihr habt bestimmt Sachen
Dokumentiert oder
Wenn ja ist das das Problem
Es muss funktionieren
Es muss nicht dokumentiert werden
Und auch noch
Es wird ja immer schlimmer
Guck mal wie viel
Manpower und
Mannjahre und sowas
Da wieder gewastet wurden für Tests und Dokumente
In der Retrospektive sollte das dringend angesprochen werden
Also erstens immer diagonal skalieren
Ganz richtig
Korrekt
Und es muss funktionieren
Weil wenn es funktioniert braucht es keine Tests
Keine Dokumentation
Und sonst nix
Keine Maintenance
Es funktioniert einfach
Übrigens Andreas
Worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte
Massive High IQ
Five Head Messages heute
Das muss man ja auch mal
Anerkennen
Ich überweis Bezos einfach mal selbst
3,99€ gerade
Von denen ich
Die Hälfte immerhin zurück bekomme
Hat sich also richtig gelohnt Subs zu giften
Aber Sub giften lohnt sich nie
Also für mich
Also wenn ich selbst auf meinem Channel
Jemandem einen Sub gifte
Lohnt sich das nicht
Wäre ja auch blöd wenn sich das lohnt
Weil dann wäre das der Infinite Money Klitsch
Würdest du dir einfach unendliche Subs selbst giften
Ne du hast heute nicht
High IQ genug
Moment Moment
Steuer wiederholen heißt nicht das man das 1 zu 1 wieder bekommt
Nur wenn ich das angebe
Wenn ich das angebe das ich irgendwie
Werbekosten was auch immer wie man das dann nennt
Habe
Dann wirkt sich das insgesamt vielleicht ein bisschen
Auf meinen Steuersatz
Minimalst aus
Ich krieg das Geld dadurch nicht wieder
Ja ab nächstes mal muss natürlich manuell sein
Selbst verlängert werden das ist ja logisch
Ja komm Leute
Aus reiner Nächstenliebe
Mach ich das ja auch nicht
Komm in die Gruppe
Ah ja ja
Leute ich werd noch zum richtigen Anime Gucker
Ich sags euch
Letzten Tage richtig viel Zeug geguckt
Und warum
Weil die ganzen Streamingdienste
Alle anfangen mich abzufacken
Deswegen
Stream ich mir jetzt einfach irgendwelche Animes
Die
Die ich ja alle nicht kenne
Weil ich nie welche geguckt habe
Kurzartig
Und die kann man sich kostenlos streamen
Ohne das die irgendeinen Streamingdienst
Kostenlos Grauzone
Ohne das sich irgendein Streamingdienst abfuckt
Amazon geht mir auf den Keks
Mit Werbung
Netflix wird immer teurer hat immer mehr Shit
Und fuckt mich allgemein schon lange ab
Alles andere ist auch für den Arsch
Und Anime Sachen ist so Grauzone
Weil es da kein also oftmals halt keiner die Rechte
Irgendwie in Deutschland dran hat
Nein können wir nicht
Können wir nicht
Das wäre auf jeden Fall
Monkatos
Das wäre definitiv Monkatos
Ja
Naja vielleicht
Übrigens Leute mein Strike auf Twitch von Apple
Ist weg
Schon seit einer ganzen Weile
Ich wurde ja mal gestrikt von Apple
Beziehungsweise von einer Anwaltskanzlei
Die im Auftrag von Apple agiert
WSL2 ist Pog
Naja
Wenn man sonst keine Möglichkeit für Linux hat
Mag das Pog sein
Ja weil Apple hat sich
Irgendwie ein Jahr später oder so
Nachdem sie mich mal gestrikt haben
Dafür entschieden das es doch nice ist
Wenn die Leute das auf Twitch streamen
Apple braucht ja immer ein bisschen für sowas
Und dann wurde mein Strike auch revoked
Ne Apple macht es nicht mehr
Apple äh
Lässt die Leute jetzt streamen
Zumindest die letzten Male immer
Dafür ist WSA jetzt updated
Was ist WSA?
Bist du Max FPS?
Ich bin Wobblos
Windows
Moment das ist was?
Das ist outdated
Ich hab nie mitbekommen das es überhaupt raus kommt
Das es überhaupt raus gekommen ist
Das haben die immer wieder verschoben
Diese Android Emulator
Geschichte für Windows
Und jetzt ist es outdated
Oder was
Das hat niemand mitbekommen das es überhaupt existiert
Naja
Aber ja du hast mich erwischt
Ich bin das
Und warum ich anders heiße
Das ist auch einfach erklärt
Also ursprünglich kommt es daher
Weil der Account älter ist
Als ich vor hatte zu streamen
Und ich nicht Max FPS
Der Max FPS gehörte übrigens auch mir
Ich könnte mich umbenennen
Aber eigentlich will ich mich gar nicht umbenennen
Weil es hat einen großen Vorteil
Nur die High IQ Leute wie du kommen her
Und checken das
Ich bin eh zu dumm und kapierens nicht
Also deswegen finde ich das
Mit zweitem Namen eigentlich ganz nice
Aber allzu viele
Ja geistige Transferleistungen
Muss man ja auch nicht leisten
Bei dem bescheuerten Namen
Und dem Avatar sollte es auch
Vielen klar sein wenn sie es das erste mal sehen
Das gab es im Amazon App Store
Ja gut das benutzt ja auch niemand
Warum gab es das nicht
Über Winget wenigstens
VMware VM
Ist doch nice
Das ist kein WSL
WSL2 ist zwar unter der Haube
Eine Hyper-VVM
Aber die versuchen ja ganz viel
Windows Integration
Du hast ja dort nicht irgendwie
Wie bei mir ein vollständiges
Linux mit grafischer Oberfläche
Wo du kaum noch einen Unterschied
Zu Native merkst
Du hast ja nur die VM für Linux Curl
Und grafische Ausgaben
Gehen ja über Windows Software
Beziehungsweise über diese komische
WSLG Geschichte
Wo man mehrere Probleme hat
Also das beste
Für mich ist
Windows auf dem Host
Auf dem zweiten Desktop
Linux mit VMware
Beste
Interessiert dich
Ja das kommt die Tage raus
Der zweite Teil
Oder heute sogar
Ist nicht mal lang
Ja und sogar auf YouTube steht sogar der Twitch Account
Ja das kommt auch noch dabei
So schon wieder weg
Insta live
Du bist noch da
Jetzt nachdem du mich
Exposed hast
Ja ich habs mit Sway auch schon ausprobiert
Sway geht bei mir nicht gescheit
Weil Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert
Und Wayland
Immer noch Copy-Paste Probleme hat
Mit bestimmten
Achso Moment
Nicht nur Copy-Paste Probleme
Der Screen Refresht nicht
Ich sehe nix
Wenn du Gnome laufen lässt
In Wayland und so
Dann funzt das komischerweise in der VM
Aber Sway nicht
Was haben wir heute gemacht mit Golang
Wir haben ein
Prometheus Exporter gebaut
Der Blockchain Sachen
Abfragt
Und bereitstellt als
Eigene Metriken
Hast du dich damals auch schon mit Crypto
Beschäftigt was ist damals
Auf welchem Zeitpunkt
Ich beschäftige mich
Eigentlich gar nicht groß mit Crypto
Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt
Wie viele Bullshit Coins
Auf Twitter täglich trenden
Ich beschäftige mich nur mit Crypto
Was
Das Projekt auf meine Arbeit angeht
Und da ist
Weder hier
Dogecoin noch
Die Dinger die aktuell
Auf Twitter trenden dabei
Also bist du kein Crypto Millionär
Moment
Oh oh
Ein Milliardär macht das nicht
Bist du kein Crypto Milliardär
Das habe ich nicht gesagt
Aber nein
Ich bin kein Crypto Milliardär
Ich könnte sicherlich Milliardär
In der Crypto Währung sein
Die nix wert ist
Und dort in Zahlen Milliarden haben
Aber bringt mir ja nix
Wenn es im Endeffekt keine Kohle für gibt
Warum habt ihr euch für Blockchain entschieden
Wurde das vorgegeben
Wie erkläre ich das am besten
Weil die auch coole Projekte machen wollen mal
Das Problem ist dass das eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr gehypt ist
Aber wenn sowas bei Versicherungen
Und Banken
Und Finanzbranche ankommt
Dann ist die Sache meistens schon outdated
Die Sinnhaftigkeit
Erschließt sich mir auch nicht wirklich gerade
Was die eigentlich da
Also ich meine ich weiß was die machen wollen
Aber wie gesagt die Sinnhaftigkeit
Erschließt sich mir nur so am Rande
Aber soll mir recht sein
Ich find's mega nice
Das liegt weniger
An der Crypto Geschichte
Sondern
Was ich mit Google Cloud
Und allem drum herum bauen kann
Find ich sehr nice
Und Kubernetes oben drauf
Und jetzt auch demnächst noch
Monitoring über Prometheus
Hier mit eigenem Exporter und sowas
Also das hat schon einen Sinn was wir hier gebaut haben
Das wird mehr oder weniger
So bei mir dann auf der Arbeit eingesetzt
Ich meine
Nicht mit gegen Polygon Scan
Die Abfrage ins Internet
Und auch nicht solche Unsinsmetriken
Aber im Prinzip
Sowas sehr ähnliches wird da eingesetzt
Bei uns dauern
Dailys 15 Minuten für 11 Leute
Ist das zu viel? Ne das ist ziemlich gut
In 10 Jahren machen wir KI
Ja
Also ich geh davon aus wir machen KI
Vielleicht in 5 Jahren schon
Also wir machen aber KI auf jeden Fall erst
Wenn der Hype vorbei ist
Also ich find 15 Minuten für 11 Leute
Sehr gut ehrlich gesagt
Ja ich kenn das auch
Wir haben halt auch Leute gerne
Die können ohne Probleme
30 Minuten Monolog halten
Aber beschweren sich dann
Wenn
Wenn du mal 2 Sätze
Nicht mit ihnen wechselst
Ja also
Ich find das ziemlich gut
15 Minuten für 11 Leute
Ich sag bei den meisten Dailys eh
Dass ich nix hab
Dann ist man schneller durch
Ok 226 Leute
Bad getimed
Was Chat
Und keiner von euch hat was gesagt
Boomer müde Boomer schlafen
Bad getimed
Nice das Stream schön das ihr da wart
Wir hören uns
Ja
Bald auf jeden Fall wie bald
Weiß ich nicht
Vielleicht baue ich morgen noch was an dem Exporter
Dann stream ich nochmal
Oder was anderes
Aber morgen muss ich eigentlich MMO Kreiselgrind machen wieder
Stellt euch mal vor
Im MMO wo ich spiele
In ner Gilde
Und aus dem nichts promotet mich einer zu Guild Leader
Die Begründung dafür war
Du bist doch eh immer da
Hahaha
Und das dumme ist
Letzten 2 Tage gab es übelst Drama
Weil Leute auf dem Server
Irgendeine Scheiße gebaut haben aus
Ist nicht wirklich meine Gilde
Und
Ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock mich mit Drama auseinanderzusetzen
Ich hab jetzt 2 andere auch
Zum Gildenleiter befördert
Ich muss mich da um kümmern
So Drama Sachen hab ich echt keinen Bock drauf
Aber die haben das echt gut gemacht
Muss man ihnen ja mal zugute halten
Ich war ja nicht da die letzten 2 Tage
Ja du hast es nicht ausgelöst
Aber Katrik
Ich kann dir erzählen was war
Du hast das Game ja auch gespielt
Leute haben irgendwie
Man kann nicht sagen nen Bug ausgenutzt
Aber sagen wir mal Vorteile ausgenutzt
Um
Mit 8 Leuten
Sagen wir mal 70 Leute zu killen
Die waren auf EV
Und haben PvP eingeschaltet
Was du ja machen kannst für 8er Gruppen dort
Und haben die ganze
Mit BG gebombt
Und kannst dir ja vorstellen
Der Obermalacca war sehr
Wenig erfreut da drüber
Aber man muss auch sagen
Die haben sich auch Infos aus Discord
Und BG Chat geholt
Und haben dann direkt am richtigen Punkt gewartet
Und so
Und dann war es wirklich Assi Aktion
Ja und anscheinend war der
Crew Leader aus meiner Gilde
Und
Ich war nicht da
Und sie haben sich alle übelst aufgeregt
Jetzt habe ich 2 andere Leute befördert
Die noch öfters da sind als ich
Jetzt ist alles gut
MMO Drama beste
Ich finde das immer geil
Es erinnert mich immer so an 2003
Wo ich viel MMOs gespielt habe
Okay Chat jetzt bin ich auch wirklich off